Need a vehicle that isn't afraid to make a splash? That's the Volkswagen Taos. Capable and confident, the Volkswagen Taos is fit for everyday life. Nimble in traffic, agile and tight spots, and still spacious enough for weekend getaways. While available 4-motion all-wheel drive gives confidence in rain and snow. The capable Taos, you deserve more confidence. Visit vw.ca to learn more. SuvW, German engineered for all.
需要一辆不怕激起浪花的座驾吗？那就是大众Taos。大众Taos既有能力又充满自信，非常适合日常生活。它在车流中灵活自如，在狭窄空间里敏捷轻快，同时又拥有足够的空间供周末出游。而可选的4-Motion全轮驱动系统则能在雨雪天气中为您提供信心。能力出众的Taos，您值得拥有更多自信。访问vw.ca了解更多。SuvW，为所有人打造的德系工程。
presents Laura versus fruit flies. Swarming your fruit and terrorizing your kitchen, these little freaks multiply at a rate that would make a rabbit say, yo, chill. But Laura shopped on Amazon and saved on cleaning spray, countertop wipes, and fly traps. Hey, fruit flies, your baby boom ends here. Save the Everyday with Amazon. Welcome aboard Via Rail. Please sit and enjoy. Please sit and sip. Play.
为您呈现：劳拉大战果蝇。这些小怪物成群结队地出现在你的水果上，恐吓着你的厨房，它们的繁殖速度快到会让兔子都说：“嘿，冷静点。”但劳拉在亚马逊上购物，省下了清洁喷雾、台面湿巾和捕蝇器的钱。嘿，果蝇们，你们的婴儿潮到此为止了。用亚马逊节省日常开支。欢迎乘坐维亚铁路（Via Rail）。请坐下享受旅程。请坐下小酌一杯。播放。
Post. Taste. View and enjoy. Via Rail, love the way. They are punk rockers. The new craze, they tell me. They're heroes. Not the nice, clean rolling stones.
发布。品味。观看并享受。维亚铁路，爱上这段旅程。他们是朋克摇滚乐手。他们告诉我，这是新潮流。他们是英雄。不是那种温和、干净的滚石乐队。
You see, they're as drunk as I am. They're clean by comparison. They're a group called the sex pistols, and I am surrounded by all of them. Now, I want to know one thing. Beethoven, Mozart, Bach and Brabts. They're all heroes of ours, isn't they? Really? What? What were you saying, sir? Oh, they're wonderful people.
你看，他们和我一样醉。相比之下，他们还算干净。他们是一个叫“性手枪”（Sex Pistols）的乐队，我被他们所有人包围着。现在，我想知道一件事。贝多芬、莫扎特、巴赫和勃拉姆斯。他们都是我们的英雄，不是吗？真的吗？什么？您刚才说什么，先生？哦，他们是了不起的人。
Are they? Oh, yes. They really turn us on. Well, suppose they turn other people on. That's just they're tough shit. It's what? Nothing. A rude word. Next question. No, no. What was the rude word? Shit. Was it really? Good heavens, you frightened me to death. So that was an archive recording of the appearance by the punk rockers, the sex pistols, on the early evening TV show today, which went out
是吗？哦，是的。他们确实让我们兴奋。好吧，假设他们让其他人也兴奋。那是他们倒霉。那是……什么？没什么。一个粗俗的词。下一个问题。不，不。那个粗俗的词是什么？“Shit”（狗屎）。真的是吗？天哪，你吓死我了。所以，那段档案录音是朋克摇滚乐队“性手枪”在傍晚电视节目《今天》中的亮相，该节目播出时……
only in London, actually, not nationally, just before 7pm on the evening of the 1st of December 1976. And the presenter as voiced by Dominic was Bill Grundy. I mean, the poor man, he became completely defined by that one interview, didn't they? It's basically the only thing he's remembered for now. And he completely lost control of the interview. And for some inexplicable reason, he just kept kind of goading them into coming out with more and more foul language. I suppose the big question is, was he actually drunk as he said he was at the start of the show? It doesn't sound massively drunk, but maybe he was good at hiding it. Well, we discussed how I should do that beforehand, didn't we?
实际上只在伦敦播出，并没有在全国范围内播放，时间是1976年12月1日傍晚7点之前。由多米尼克配音的主持人是比尔·格伦迪（Bill Grundy）。我的意思是，这个可怜的人，他完全被那一次采访定义了，不是吗？这基本上是他现在唯一被人们记住的事情。他完全失去了对采访的控制。出于某种无法解释的原因，他只是不断地怂恿他们说出越来越多的脏话。我想最大的问题是，他当时真的像他在节目开始时说的那样喝醉了吗？听起来并不像是烂醉如泥，但也许他很擅长掩饰。好吧，我们之前讨论过我该怎么做，不是吗？
And you said I should do it slurring my words, obviously drunk. But actually, when you watch the clip, he isn't obviously drunk, I wouldn't say? I mean, it's just inexplicable why he goes them into more and more swearing, and we will come to this, weren't we? I mean, Sex Pistols thought he was drunk when they were asked about it later. They did, yeah. But he got through the rest of the program, okay, this is just at the very end of the program. And this is the moment when the Sex Pistols kind of... blowed on to national consciousness.
你说我应该含糊不清地说话，表现得明显喝醉了。但实际上，当你观看这段视频时，他并不明显是醉了，我不会这么说？我的意思是，他为什么怂恿他们说越来越多的脏话，这简直无法解释，我们稍后会谈到这一点，不是吗？我的意思是，后来当被问及此事时，“性手枪”乐队认为他喝醉了。他们确实这么认为。但他完成了节目的其余部分，没问题，这只是在节目的最后。这就是“性手枪”乐队……闯入全国公众意识的时刻。
Yes, it is. So this is 1976, and the next day, they were on the front pages of all the newspapers, the great headline in the mirror, I think it is, the filth and the fury. And from that moment on, they became household names. It's a rocker-row spindle. So I would say that if you look back at the previous 20 years, only the Beatles and the Rolling Stones had matched that level of fame or notoriety. And here's the funny thing.
是的，确实如此。所以这是1976年，第二天，他们登上了所有报纸的头版，我想《镜报》上的大标题是“污秽与愤怒”（The Filth and the Fury）。从那一刻起，他们成了家喻户晓的名字。这真是一场摇滚风暴。所以我认为，如果你回顾过去20年，只有披头士乐队和滚石乐队达到了那种名声或臭名昭著的程度。有趣的事情来了。
At this point, the Sex Pistols had not released a single record. It's Malcolm McLaren's masterpiece, isn't it? Yeah, that they are a media phenomenon in a way before they're a musical phenomenon. Anyway, we will come on to this interview later in the show, and maybe Tom will play another bit of that excellent archive footage. Because Susie Sue, as in The Banshees, is also there. I think it's the first TV appearance. I'm looking forward to hearing her.
在这一点上，“性手枪”乐队还没有发行过一张唱片。这是马尔科姆·麦克拉伦（Malcolm McLaren）的杰作，不是吗？是的，他们在成为音乐现象之前，在某种程度上先成为了一种媒体现象。无论如何，我们稍后会在节目中谈到这次采访，也许汤姆会播放另一段精彩的档案片段。因为苏西·苏（Siouxsie Sioux），也就是“苏西与女妖”乐队的主唱，当时也在场。我想这是她的第一次电视亮相。我很期待听到她的声音。
Yeah. So what's so interesting about this is that this was broadcast on the very evening that one of the most humiliating political and economic dramas in modern British history was coming to a climax. So it's an intersection point between two different but arguably related things. So the first is the economic crisis that we've been tracing through this series. The pound and free fall, Britain staring into the economic abyss and the new Prime Minister, Jim Callaghan. he has been forced to go to the International Monetary Fund for a humiliating record bailout of almost $4 billion. So his cabinet is divided, and this very evening is the moment of decision.
是的。所以这最有趣的地方在于，这正是在现代英国历史上最令人羞辱的政治和经济戏剧之一达到高潮的那个晚上播出的。所以这是两个不同但可以说相关的事情的交汇点。首先是我们在这系列节目中一直追踪的经济危机。英镑处于自由落体状态，英国凝视着经济深渊，新任首相吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan）被迫向国际货币基金组织（IMF）寻求近40亿美元的创纪录羞辱性救助。所以他的内阁四分五裂，而这个晚上正是决定的时刻。
And the second thing is that against the backdrop of the economic crisis, the inflation, the surge in youth unemployment, the sense of national failure and national breakdown, this new kind of music has come out of Britain's art colleges and pubs and clubs. It was initially called by the press Dole Cue. rock, better known as punk, and embodied by John Leiden or Johnny Rotten and his fellow sex pistols. And this is the evening that defines them forever as the ultimate 1970s folk devils. And so this is the story of today's episode, the intersection of these two stories, obviously
第二件事是，在经济危机、通货膨胀、青年失业率飙升、国家失败感和国家崩溃感的背景下，这种新音乐从英国的艺术学院、酒吧和俱乐部中涌现出来。它最初被媒体称为“救济金摇滚”（Dole Cue rock），更广为人知的名字是朋克，由约翰·莱顿（John Lydon）或约翰尼·罗顿（Johnny Rotten）和他的“性手枪”队友所体现。这就是那个让他们永远被定义为20世纪70年代终极“民间恶魔”的夜晚。所以这就是今天这一集的故事，这两个故事的交汇，显然……
the primary focus being on the political one, and it's the climax of our series on 1975 and 1976. And we'll start with the main character in the drama, and now we introduced last time, top British Prime Minister, Jim Callaghan. So last time, Callaghan won the Labour leadership in the last episode, but we didn't really dig into his personality. And now at last, after 700 episodes of the rest is history or whatever it is, we finally get to talk about one of the undisputed Great Britons, and that is Sonny Jim.
主要焦点是政治故事，这是我们关于1975年和1976年系列节目的高潮。我们将从戏剧中的主角开始，我们上次介绍过，英国顶级首相吉姆·卡拉汉。上次，卡拉汉在上一集中赢得了工党领袖的职位，但我们并没有真正深入挖掘他的个性。现在终于，在《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）或其他什么节目的700集之后，我们终于可以谈谈无可争议的伟大英国人之一，那就是“桑尼·吉姆”（Sonny Jim）。
So he was born Leonard James Callaghan in Portsmouth in 1912, in a working class house in the shadow of the Docks, the Royal Navy Docks. His father was a chief petty officer who died when Callahan was nine. Callahan was called Len, but when he became an adult, he renamed himself James, because James was his father's name. So it's a little sort of nod to his late father, which I think is very nice. It wasn't that he thought that James would he'd be likely to become Prime Minister? I don't think so, because Len Murray at the same time became head of the TUC.
他于1912年出生在朴茨茅斯的伦纳德·詹姆斯·卡拉汉，住在一座位于皇家海军码头阴影下的工人阶级房子里。他的父亲是一名首席士官，在卡拉汉九岁时去世。卡拉汉当时叫伦（Len），但当他成年后，他把自己改名为詹姆斯，因为詹姆斯是他父亲的名字。所以我认为这对他已故父亲是一种很好的致敬。并不是说他认为叫詹姆斯就更有可能成为首相？我不这么认为，因为伦·默里（Len Murray）在同一时间成为了英国工会联盟（TUC）的负责人。
Len is a union name. I think James is the Prime Minister name. I think he would still have been Prime Minister if he was called Len. So he is shaped by his father's background to some extent. So the big thing he gets from his father is his love of the Royal Navy. And we admire that, don't we, Tom? We respect that. Very much.
伦是一个工会名字。我认为詹姆斯是一个首相名字。我想如果他叫伦，他仍然会成为首相。所以他在某种程度上受到他父亲背景的影响。他从父亲那里得到的最重要的东西就是他对皇家海军的热爱。我们很钦佩这一点，不是吗，汤姆？我们非常尊重这一点。非常尊重。
He adores the Navy. He adores its service, its duty, its patriotism, comradeship. Later on in life, he collects naval prints. Oh, like Keith Richards. Yes, exactly. He would have bonded with Keith Richards over Naval Prince. He sees the Navy, I think, as a model for the Labour Party and indeed for Britain. And then what he gets from his mother is his back.
他崇拜海军。他崇拜它的服务、它的职责、它的爱国主义、同志情谊。晚年，他收集海军版画。哦，就像基思·理查兹（Keith Richards）一样。是的，没错。他会因为海军版画而与基思·理查兹建立联系。我认为他将海军视为工党乃至英国的典范。然后他从母亲那里得到的是他的……
Baptist faith. So his mother is a very strict Baptist. He went to Sunday school every week. He learned passages of the Bible and he was very comfortable with kind of biblical references. Actually, it's something he has in common with Margaret Thatcher. I was just thinking that. I was thinking how many of the leading politicians in this generation and period come from low church backgrounds and how the collapse of kind of low church backgrounds in politics, I think is a bit of a tragedy. I totally agree with you. It gives people a sort of moral core, doesn't it? And not just a moral core. It gives them a language, I think. Yeah, a sensibility. Exactly, all of that kind of thing, which Callaghan and Thatcher in their different ways, completely embody. And it gives him actually that, the Baptist
浸信会信仰。所以他的母亲是一位非常严格的浸信会教徒。他每周都去主日学校。他学习圣经段落，并且对圣经引用非常熟悉。实际上，这是他和玛格丽特·撒切尔（Margaret Thatcher）的共同点。我刚才就在想这个。我在想，这一代和这一时期的许多主要政治家都来自低教会背景，而低教会背景在政治中的崩溃，我认为是一个悲剧。我完全同意你的看法。这给了人们一种道德核心，不是吗？不仅仅是道德核心。我认为这给了他们一种语言。是的，一种感性。没错，所有这些东西，卡拉汉和撒切尔以各自不同的方式完全体现了这一点。这实际上给了他，浸信会……
stuff and the Royal Navy gives him this profound cultural conservatism, which we'll talk about in a second. He left Portsmouth Northern secondary school when he was 17. He became a tax clerk, then trade union official. He served in the East Indies fleet in the Second World War. He became a very young Labour MP in 1945. And then he was a junior minister. at the age of 35, and through sheer sort of doggedness and resilience, he made it to the top. He was a useless chancellor in the 1960s under Harold Wilson. But then Wilson gave him another chance as Home Secretary. He was very sort of solid, I think.
以及皇家海军的经历赋予了他这种深刻的文化保守主义，我们稍后会谈到。他17岁时离开了朴茨茅斯北部中学。他成为了一名税务员，然后是工会官员。他在第二次世界大战期间在东印度舰队服役。他于1945年成为一名非常年轻的工党议员。然后他在35岁时担任初级部长。凭借纯粹的坚韧和毅力，他登上了顶峰。他在20世纪60年代哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）手下担任财政大臣时表现平平。但后来威尔逊给了他另一个机会，让他担任内政大臣。我认为他非常稳重。
He loved the police, so he sort of, home secretary suited him. Late 60s, is the period when the kind of permissive society is. Yeah, but he hates the permissive society, and the people love that. Yeah. He's very much into policemen cracking. students over the head. Or giving them a clip around the ear. I think that's what he would say.
他热爱警察，所以内政大臣这个职位很适合他。60年代末是那种“宽容社会”的时期。是的，但他讨厌宽容社会，而人们喜欢这一点。是的。他非常支持警察敲打学生的脑袋。或者给他们一个耳光。我想他会这么说。
Give them a clip around the year and tell them to get their hair cut. And the Tom Holland tendency shake their head sadly at that, but the Dominic Sam Brooks cheer and applaud and tears of pride spring to their eyes. So I think that's very much his vibe. And then he was Foreign Secretary in the early 70s. In his politics, he is the quintessential embodiment of the old Labour right. So the right of the party, but sort of backwards. looking, old-fashioned, moderate, pragmatic, patriotic.
给他们一个耳光，告诉他们去理发。汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）倾向的人会对此悲伤地摇头，但多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）倾向的人会欢呼鼓掌，自豪的泪水涌上眼眶。所以我认为这非常符合他的风格。然后他在70年代初担任外交大臣。在政治上，他是老工党右翼的典型化身。所以是党的右翼，但有点守旧、老派、务实、务实、爱国。
Patriotic is a key word, isn't it? The friend of the British working man, that's his thing. So he was the parliamentary spokesman for the Police Federation, and that really sums him up. He's a big guy, he's breezy, as we said, by law, you have to call him avuncular. He has this bruiser reputation, but he has flashes of self-doubt, because as we learned last time, The fact that he didn't go to university and that he's not an intellectual weighs quite heavily on him, his great rival was Roy Jenkins who absolutely despised him. Bailey, old man.
爱国是一个关键词，不是吗？英国工人的朋友，这就是他的风格。所以他是警察联合会的议会发言人，这真的总结了他的一切。他是个大块头，他很轻松，正如我们所说，法律规定你必须称他为“和蔼可亲的”。他有这种“打手”的名声，但他也有自我怀疑的时刻，因为正如我们上次了解到的，他没有上过大学且不是知识分子的事实对他影响很大，他最大的竞争对手是罗伊·詹金斯（Roy Jenkins），他绝对鄙视他。贝利，老兄。
Roy Jenkins said later, there is no case I can think of in history where a man combines such a powerful political personality with so little intelligence. But only one man in British history, as we said last time, has been Chancellor, Home Secretary, Foreign Secretary and Prime Minister. And that man was not Roy Jenkins. it was Jim Callahan. However, Jim Callahan did not become European Commissioner. Yeah, he wouldn't have wanted to, I think. It's not really his vibe.
罗伊·詹金斯后来曾说，在历史上我能想到的任何案例中，没有一个人能将如此强大的政治个性和如此少的智慧结合在一起。但正如我们上次所说，英国历史上只有一个人担任过财政大臣、内政大臣、外交大臣和首相。那个人不是罗伊·詹金斯，而是吉姆·卡拉汉。然而，吉姆·卡拉汉没有成为欧盟委员。是的，我想他也不会想成为。那真的不是他的风格。
Yeah, I'm just saying, I'm just sticking out for Woy. Sometimes people say of Callahan, I think not unreasonably, he was the last true conservative to be Prime Minister, small C conservative. So his likes are rugby, the Labour Party, the trade unions, and like Harold Wilson, he loves the Boy Scouts. Did he wear tight trousers? I can't imagine him in tight trousers.
是的，我只是说，我只是在为“Woy”（罗伊·詹金斯的昵称）辩护。有时人们说卡拉汉，我认为并非不合理，他是最后一位担任首相的真正保守派，小写的“c”保守派。所以他的爱好是橄榄球、工党、工会，而且像哈罗德·威尔逊一样，他热爱童子军。他穿紧身裤吗？我无法想象他穿紧身裤的样子。
Never. He wore long, baggy, high-wasted trousers. He hates it when his lefty activists criticise the police or the armed forces or the queen. The queen, he loves the queen. He's a teetotler. He hates any hint of permissiveness or sexual misbehavior. He and his wife Audrey met when they were 17 and 16 respectively, and they're incredibly devoted. When he was prime minister, he told his staff, there's a lovely bit in Sir Bernard Donahue carried on working for Callaghan after Wilson left, so we get these fantastic diaries. And Callahan says at one point, he's embarrassed by nudity on TV or on the stage. So whenever he sees nudity on TV, he has to turn it off, even though he's in his 60s.
绝不。他穿长长的、宽松的、高腰的裤子。他讨厌左翼活动家批评警察、军队或女王。女王，他爱女王。他是个禁酒主义者。他讨厌任何暗示宽容或性不检点的行为。他和他的妻子奥黛丽分别在17岁和16岁时相识，他们非常恩爱。当他担任首相时，他告诉他的员工，伯纳德·多纳休（Sir Bernard Donahue）爵士在威尔逊离开后继续为卡拉汉工作，所以我们得到了这些精彩的日记。卡拉汉在某个时候说，他对电视或舞台上的裸露感到尴尬。所以每当他在电视上看到裸露镜头时，他都必须关掉它，尽管他已经60多岁了。
He said, he was completely unaware of homosexuality until well into adult life. This is a man who served in the Navy. Navy, exactly. He only found out about it when he became an MP. And he was amazed when some of his aide said to him, Some of you all are MPs are gay. He was like, what? I don't believe that.
他说，直到成年很久之后，他才完全意识到同性恋的存在。这是一个在海军服役过的人。海军，没错。他直到成为议员后才发现这一点。当他的一些助手对他说“你们工党议员中有些人是同性恋”时，他感到很惊讶。他当时想，什么？我不相信。
And then at this point, in the same conversation, they're all sitting around, it's kind of in a circle, and one of the MPs tells the story about a very camp cook that he knew in the Royal Navy. Callahan is stunned by this. And he says, in the Navy, I never knew anybody like that when I was in the Navy. And they're all kind of smirking at this. They can't believe that he would be so innocent. And then he says to them brilliantly,
然后在同一场谈话中，他们都坐在那里，围成一个圈，其中一位议员讲了一个关于他在皇家海军认识的一位非常女性化的厨师的故事。卡拉汉对此感到震惊。他说：“在海军里，我在海军时从没见过那样的人。”他们都对此窃笑。他们不敢相信他会如此天真。然后他精彩地对他们说：
you won't tell these stories in front of Audrey, will you? She would be very shocked. So there's a sort of Puritanism to the Callagans. And the most common comparison when he becomes Prime Minister is with another absolutely top person. So the champion of our first historical Love Island, 1920s and 1930s Prime Minister, Stanley Baldwin. Everybody basically said, oh, it's like Stanley Baldwin's come back from the dead. Because although they're in different parties, they're both small sea conservatives, they're both pragmatic, they're both kind of good, humid, they're both nostalgic, and they're both really, really good. communicators.
“你们不会在奥黛丽面前讲这些故事吧？她会非常震惊的。”所以卡拉汉夫妇有一种清教徒主义。当他成为首相时，最常见的比较是与另一位绝对顶级的人物进行比较。也就是我们第一次历史性“恋爱岛”的冠军，20世纪20年代和30年代的首相斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）。每个人基本上都说，哦，就像斯坦利·鲍德温死而复生了。因为尽管他们属于不同的政党，但他们都是小写的“c”保守派，他们都很务实，都很幽默，都很怀旧，而且他们都是非常、非常好的沟通者。
And like Baldwin, Callaghan cultivates this yeoman image. So he bought a farm in East Sussex, and he would go and slightly ostentatiously spend his weekends inspecting his cows and trudging the fields under a sort of tweed hat. It's a bit like Mariantoinette in a very real sense. That's not a comparison. No. Improbable. That's a terrible comparison.
像鲍德温一样，卡拉汉培养了这种“自耕农”形象。所以他在东萨塞克斯郡买了一个农场，他会稍微显摆地花周末时间去视察他的奶牛，戴着一顶粗花呢帽子在田野里跋涉。从某种真实意义上讲，这有点像玛丽·安托瓦内特（Marie Antoinette）。那不是一个比较。不。不可能。那是一个糟糕的比较。
Because I think he's John Bull. That's exactly what he is. He's big, he's heavy, he's kind of slightly slow, he's very solid, he's very respectable. As PM, he wears these pinstriped dark suits and he has these colossal glasses. Oh yeah, we mentioned them in the previous episode. People love it. So actually, when you look at the opinion polls, he's consistently an extremely popular prime minister. And right to the end, he is far more popular than Margaret Thatcher.
因为我认为他是“约翰牛”（John Bull）。这正是他的样子。他高大、沉重、有点慢，非常稳重，非常受人尊敬。作为首相，他穿着这些细条纹深色西装，戴着这些巨大的眼镜。哦，是的，我们在上一集中提到过。人们喜欢它。所以实际上，当你查看民意调查时，他一直是一位非常受欢迎的首相。直到最后，他都比玛格丽特·撒切尔受欢迎得多。
Basically, if the 1979 election had been, you know, if you'd be able to mix and match what the British people actually wanted in 1970s. was the Conservatives to Wimba with Callahan as Prime Minister. I mean, would he have made a good Conservative Prime Minister? He's a monetarist. He doesn't like gay people. I don't think he dislikes gay people. He's just not aware they exist. He would have made a good frontman for a sort of national government.
基本上，如果1979年的选举是，你知道，如果你能混合搭配英国人民在70年代真正想要的东西，那就是由卡拉汉担任首相的保守党。我的意思是，他会成为一位好的保守党首相吗？他是货币主义者。他不讨厌同性恋。我不认为他讨厌同性恋。他只是不知道他们的存在。他会成为某种国民政府的优秀代言人。
He'd made a brilliant front man for a national government. But that said, he loves the Labour Party. I don't want to dismiss that element. He really loves the Labour Party and the British kind of working classes. More than Harold Wilson had done? Yeah, possibly. He's a, you know, people when they watch him out on the start, They say, God, he's so great with the public.
他会成为国民政府的杰出代言人。但话虽如此，他热爱工党。我不想忽视那个因素。他真的热爱工党和英国的工人阶级。比哈罗德·威尔逊做得更多？是的，可能。他是一个，你知道，当人们在街上看到他时，他们会说，天哪，他与公众的关系太好了。
And I think it's partly his size. You know, he's a big bloke. And so people respect him and people are slightly frightened of him. And he uses that to his advantage. Anyway, on paper, his government isn't massively different from Wilson's. So he keeps Dennis Healy as Chancellor. We talked a bit about Healy last time. He's going to play a big part today.
我认为这部分是因为他的体型。你知道，他是个大块头。所以人们尊重他，人们对他有点敬畏。他利用这一点为自己谋利。无论如何，在纸面上，他的政府与威尔逊的政府并没有太大不同。所以他留任丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy）担任财政大臣。我们上次谈到了一点希利。他今天会扮演重要角色。
Remember his eyebrows. He was the landing officer, Anzio, and he's got a hinterland. He's the only person in history to have a cultural and intellectual hinterland. And he likes effing and blinding and lesser mortals. So during all this period, you have to imagine Dennis Healy. He's getting increasingly fatter with every week that passes because he's basically trapped behind his desk the whole time, desperately trying to cobble together money.
记住他的眉毛。他是安齐奥（Anzio）的登陆官，他有“腹地”（hinterland，指深厚的文化底蕴）。他是历史上唯一一个拥有文化和知识腹地的人。他喜欢对凡夫俗子说脏话。所以在这整个时期，你必须想象丹尼斯·希利。随着时间的推移，他变得越来越胖，因为他基本上一直被困在办公桌后面，拼命地试图凑钱。
He's incredibly red-faced. He's incredibly puffy. He looks like he's going to explode at any moment, but he's doing an amazing job. And actually, he and Callaghan worked brilliant together. It's one of the great partnerships between a prime minister and a chancellor, because usually prime ministers and chancellors end up hating each other and massively falling out and they don't.
他脸色红润得不可思议。他肿胀得不可思议。他看起来随时都要爆炸，但他做得非常出色。实际上，他和卡拉汉合作得非常棒。这是首相和财政大臣之间伟大的伙伴关系之一，因为通常首相和财政大臣最终会互相憎恨并发生严重冲突，但他们没有。
And then there's a third person in their kind of training. Unverett, who is Michael Foot, who we talked about last time again, the radical pamphleteer and fan of Jonathan Swift and Byron and co. Foot is on the left, but basically Callahan brings him into the tent and says, will you be the leader of the House of Commons? So will he be in charge of keeping the Labour Party together? And Foote is absolutely brilliant at it. He's completely loyal to Callahan, even though he doesn't agree with him. He's really loyal to him. Callahan later described him as a true comrade during all this time. Callahan contrasted him. With who, Dominic? With our old friend Tony Ben. And Callahan described Tony Ben not as a true
然后是他们训练中的第三个人，迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot），我们上次也谈到了他，激进的小册子作者，乔纳森·斯威夫特（Jonathan Swift）和拜伦等人的粉丝。富特在左翼，但卡拉汉基本上把他拉进了阵营，说：“你愿意担任下议院领袖吗？”所以他会负责保持工党的团结？富特在这方面绝对出色。他完全忠于卡拉汉，尽管他不同意他的观点。他真的很忠诚。卡拉汉后来形容他在这段时间里是一位真正的同志。卡拉汉将他与谁进行了对比，多米尼克？与我们的老朋友托尼·本（Tony Benn）。卡拉汉形容托尼·本不是一个真正的……
corrade, but as, and I quote, a canting hypocrite. I mean, people think I'm very hard on Tony Ben, but actually I find Tony Ben immensely amusing. So I'm just quoting this in a good humoured, kind-hearted spirits rather than a condemnatory one. Now, Callahan's less famous than Wilson, but almost all of their ministers thought that Callahan was a better prime minister, that he was more decisive. He didn't take any nonsense. He was firm but fair. quite wily as well, isn't he? Yeah, he is quite wily. He conceals his whiliness beneath a kind of bluff exterior. Yeah, exactly. So in 1978, one of his young ministers called Bill Rogers gave an off-the-record interview with the journalist Hugo Young, and he said, Callaghan stands for stability, a stable style and a stable government. What he cannot abide is the long-haired intellectual on all his works.
同志，而是，引用他的话，“一个虚伪的伪君子”。我的意思是，人们认为我对托尼·本太苛刻了，但实际上我发现托尼·本非常有趣。所以我只是以一种幽默、善良的精神引用这句话，而不是谴责。现在，卡拉汉不如威尔逊出名，但他们几乎所有的部长都认为卡拉汉是一位更好的首相，他更果断。他不接受任何废话。他坚定而公平。他也很狡猾，不是吗？是的，他确实很狡猾。他把狡猾隐藏在一种坦率的外表之下。是的，没错。所以1978年，他的一位年轻部长比尔·罗杰斯（Bill Rogers）接受了记者雨果·杨（Hugo Young）的非正式采访，他说：“卡拉汉代表稳定，一种稳定的风格和稳定的政府。他无法忍受的是长发知识分子及其所有作品。”
To be fair, Michael Foote is a long-haired intellectual. He is, but he's also a true comrade and not a canting hypocrite. I think that's the key thing. If you're a long-haired intellectual, but you're not a counting hypocrite, then he'll... Then you're right, yeah. If you basically bend the knee and do Jim's will, then he will tolerate you. And actually, even the Tories, at the time in the 1970s, thought that he was good. So the future Thatcher minister, Peter Walker, said publicly in 1977, we have a prime minister who is good on television, who looks like Stanley Baldwin, who lives like Stanley Baldwin, and Stanley Baldwin, with the vote of the Labour Party
公平地说，迈克尔·富特就是一位长发知识分子。他是，但他也是一位真正的同志，而不是一个虚伪的伪君子。我认为这是关键。如果你是一个长发知识分子，但你不是一个虚伪的伪君子，那么他会……那么你是对的，是的。如果你基本上屈服并执行吉姆的意志，那么他会容忍你。实际上，即使是当时的保守党人，在70年代也认为他很好。所以未来的撒切尔内阁部长彼得·沃克（Peter Walker）在1977年公开表示：“我们有一位在电视上表现出色、看起来像斯坦利·鲍德温、生活方式像斯坦利·鲍德温的首相，而斯坦利·鲍德温，加上工党的选票……
and North Sea Oil is a very formidable... opponent. I mean, he lives like Stanley Bullitt. I can't imagine James Callahan writing pornography. The key variable there is that he didn't go to Harrow, because Stanley Baldwin did that at Harrow. That's well remembered. Also, Stanley Baldwin gave a tenth of his fortune to pay off the national debt. Let's remember that. And married a cricketer. Yeah, married an excellent cricketer. Even Margaret Thatcher had warm words for Jim. She said he was a superb politician and in other circumstances would have been a successful prime minister. And what circumstances are those, Dominic? Well, you see, that's a very nice link,
和北海石油，是一个非常强大的……对手。”我的意思是，他生活得像斯坦利·鲍德温。我无法想象吉姆·卡拉汉写色情作品。那里的关键变量是他没有去过哈罗公学，因为斯坦利·鲍德温在哈罗公学做过。这一点记得很清楚。此外，斯坦利·鲍德温捐出了他十分之一的财富来偿还国债。让我们记住这一点。而且娶了一位板球运动员。是的，娶了一位出色的板球运动员。即使是玛格丽特·撒切尔对吉姆也有温暖的话语。她说他是一位出色的政治家，在其他情况下会是一位成功的首相。多米尼克，那是些什么情况？好吧，你看，那是一个非常好的衔接，
isn't it? I wrote that as a segue into the circumstances. So first of all, he's got no parliamentary majority. We described last time. Labor have no majority in the House of Commons. So every vote now is knife edge. I mean, literally life or death. They are bringing people in. These were very famous scenes in the late 70s. They would bring elderly MPs in on ambulances to vote, and sometimes they would cheat. So there's one famous example where they basically, what they would often do, is you do a thing called pairing, where you would basically, there's some 90-year-old Labor MP who's dying, there's a 90-year-old Tory MP who's dying, and you'd say, well, they can't see each other out, and neither of them have to come in and vote. And you'd agree that beforehand.
不是吗？我写那段话是为了过渡到那些情况。首先，他没有议会多数席位。我们上次描述过。工党在下议院没有多数席位。所以现在的每一次投票都处于刀刃上。我的意思是，真的是生死攸关。他们正在把人带进来。这些是70年代末非常著名的场景。他们会用救护车把年迈的议员带进来投票，有时他们会作弊。所以有一个著名的例子，他们基本上，他们经常做的是，你做一件叫“配对”（pairing）的事情，基本上就是有一个90岁的工党议员快死了，有一个90岁的保守党议员快死了，你会说，好吧，他们不能互相抵消，他们都不必进来投票。你会事先同意这一点。
And then on one occasion, Labor completely shamed themselves, going back on their word, and bringing in this bloke on a trolley or whatever to vote. And that provoked a massive fight, like a physical brawl where people are like piling into each other. Of course, this is pre-television. And this was the occasion in which a young Michael Heseltine seized the mace and kind of whirled it around his head and made it spectacle of himself and then was called Tarzan forever because of that. It's the theme of a wonderful play by James Graham called This House. Really excellent. Amazing play. That's one circumstance and the other circumstance is the economic legacy. Inflation has actually now started to fall,
然后有一次，工党完全丢了脸，违背了诺言，把这个家伙用担架或其他什么东西带进来投票。这引发了一场大规模的打斗，就像一场身体冲突，人们像是在互相堆叠。当然，这是电视普及之前。这就是年轻的迈克尔·赫塞尔廷（Michael Heseltine）抓住权杖并把它在头顶挥舞，让自己出丑，然后因为那个被称为“泰山”的场合。这是詹姆斯·格雷厄姆（James Graham）的一部精彩戏剧《议会》（This House）的主题。真的很棒。了不起的戏剧。那是一种情况，另一种情况是经济遗产。通货膨胀实际上现在已经开始下降，
but it is still about 19%. And the bigger problem is that as we described last time, the international markets have now lost confidence in Britain's ability to run its economy, not least thanks to its massive borrowing. So when Callaghan has his first meeting with Dennis Healy, Healy says to him, look, the Bank of England have just spent $2 billion in currency reserves. That's a third of their entire reserves propping up the value of sterling. And this can't continue. And the next person who comes in to see him is the governor of the Bank of England.
但它仍然在19%左右。更大的问题是，正如我们上次描述的那样，国际市场现在已经失去了对英国管理经济能力的信心，这在很大程度上要归功于其大规模的借贷。所以当卡拉汉与丹尼斯·希利进行第一次会议时，希利对他说：“看，英格兰银行刚刚花费了20亿美元的外汇储备。那是他们全部储备的三分之一，用来支撑英镑的价值。这种情况不能再继续下去了。”下一个进来见他的人是英格兰银行行长。
It's called Gordon Richardson. He says to Callaghan, you know, we're still borrowing far too much. and this pressure from the markets is not going to ease anytime soon. There is a very good chance that we are going to run out of money. And when we do that, we will have to ask the International Monetary Fund, the IMF, for a loan. Now, the IMF had been set up in 1945. It's one of the great institutions of the New World Order. By John Maynard Keynes, who is British, so it's massively embarrassing.
他叫戈登·理查森（Gordon Richardson）。他对卡拉汉说：“你知道，我们借的钱还是太多了。来自市场的压力短期内不会缓解。我们很有可能会没钱了。当我们这样做时，我们将不得不向国际货币基金组织（IMF）申请贷款。”现在，IMF成立于1945年。它是新世界秩序的伟大机构之一。由约翰·梅纳德·凯恩斯（John Maynard Keynes）创立，他是英国人，所以这非常令人尴尬。
Oh, the International Monetary Fund, some of their staff are British, some of their key figures are British. that the fact that Britain, of all people, will have to crawl to them. I think the technical term that you, again, by under UN regulations, you have to use for the IMF crisis, Britain goes cap in hand to the IMF. Because loans are meant to be given to bankrupt third world countries. Yes, exactly. A country like Britain, formerly the world's banker, should not be going to the IMF begging for cash. Now, a problem is the key contributors to the IMF are the Americans.
哦，国际货币基金组织，他们的一些员工是英国人，他们的一些关键人物是英国人。英国人竟然要向他们卑躬屈膝，这事实……我认为你根据联合国规定必须为IMF危机使用的技术术语是：英国向IMF“伸手乞讨”（cap in hand）。因为贷款本应提供给破产的第三世界国家。是的，没错。像英国这样一个曾经的世界银行家，不应该向IMF乞求现金。现在，一个问题是IMF的主要贡献者是美国人。
and politics in America at this point is well to the right. The consensus in Washington is well to the right of what it is in London. The Americans will undoubtedly ask for very stringent terms, probably cuts. They'll say you can have the money, but you have to sort your economy out. And for a Labour Prime Minister, this is obviously a nightmare. This is a massive embarrassment because there's nothing more likely to inflame your own activists than you bending the need to the forces of American international capitalism. Yeah.
而此时美国的政治非常右倾。华盛顿的共识比伦敦的共识要右得多。美国人无疑会提出非常严格的条件，可能是削减开支。他们会说你可以拿到钱，但你必须整理好你的经济。对于一位工党首相来说，这显然是一场噩梦。这是一个巨大的尴尬，因为没有什么比你向美国国际资本主义势力屈服更能激怒你自己的活动家了。是的。
And whenever people would say to Dennis Healy, Labor people would say to Dennis Healy, sort of Zach Pallansky star, they'd say, why are you taking orders from the money markets? Dennis Healy would say, well, I mean, if we don't want to take orders in the money markets, we just shouldn't borrow money from them. And in that case, we should manage our finances a bit better. You know, what are we going to do about it? We shouldn't have got into this mess in the first place. Well, when you put it like that.
每当人们对丹尼斯·希利说，工党的人会对丹尼斯·希利说，有点像扎克·帕兰斯基（Zach Pallansky）风格，他们会说：“你为什么要听从货币市场的命令？”丹尼斯·希利会说：“好吧，我的意思是，如果我们不想听从货币市场的命令，我们就不应该向他们借钱。在这种情况下，我们应该更好地管理我们的财务。你知道，我们该怎么办？我们本来就不应该陷入这种混乱。”好吧，当你这么说的时候。
Well, I mean, I agree with him, but it doesn't go down well with some of his own enthusiasts. Anyway, it takes two months for all this pressure to build, and by early June 76 it's really on. Now remember, there was a point in the last episode, the beginning of the week, when the pound was at $2.23. On the third of June, it is down to $1.70. I mean, that is an extraordinary plunge. It's lost a considerable fraction of its value, and it is still falling. And the Bank of England say to Healy, we've run out of reserves to defend it. You've got to talk to the IMF. He needs $5 billion to defend the pound. And he can probably get that informally
好吧，我的意思是，我同意他的观点，但这在一些他自己的狂热支持者中并不受欢迎。无论如何，所有这些压力积累了两个月，到76年6月初，压力真的很大。现在记住，上一集开始时，英镑兑美元汇率为2.23美元。6月3日，它跌至1.70美元。我的意思是，那是一次非凡的暴跌。它损失了相当大一部分价值，而且还在继续下跌。英格兰银行对希利说：“我们已经没有储备来捍卫它了。你必须和IMF谈谈。”他需要50亿美元来捍卫英镑。他可能可以非正式地得到这些钱，
without having the humiliation of a proper application. So he talks to the IMF and they say, look, we've cobbled together some of the money, most of it from the US Federal Reserve. We can lend you the money, but there are conditions. The chairman of the Federal Reserve, Guy good Arthur Burns, describes himself as a Neanderthal Conservative,
而不需要正式申请的羞辱。所以他与IMF进行了交谈，他们说：“看，我们凑齐了一些钱，大部分来自美国联邦储备委员会。我们可以借给你钱，但有条件。”美联储主席阿瑟·伯恩斯（Arthur Burns）形容自己是一个“尼安德特保守派”，
and he wants Britain's lefty government to learn a lesson in discipline. And then the US Treasury Secretary, Gerald Ford's Treasury Secretary, is a guy called Bill Simon. He's even more hawkish. In his memoirs, he said, I was keen to help a US ally, but I'd no desire to play host to a parasite. That's harsh. He hates Britain. And Healy said of Bill Simon, he was far to the right of Genghis Khan.
他想让英国的左翼政府接受纪律教训。然后美国财政部长，杰拉尔德·福特（Gerald Ford）的财政部长，是一个叫比尔·西蒙（Bill Simon）的人。他甚至更强硬。在他的回忆录中，他说：“我热衷于帮助美国盟友，但我不想收留一个寄生虫。”这太刻薄了。他讨厌英国。希利评价比尔·西蒙说，他比成吉思汗还要右得多。
Displaying his hinterland there. Yeah, very good. A witty historical illusion. His historical knowledge. Yeah. You wouldn't get that from politicians today, would you? Such an obscure reference from Dennis Healy. So anyway, the deal is this.
在那里展示了他的腹地。是的，非常好。一个机智的历史典故。他的历史知识。是的。你今天在政治家中不会得到那种东西，不是吗？丹尼斯·希利如此晦涩的引用。所以无论如何，交易是这样的。
Britain will get its $5 billion, but it has six months to pay it back. And if Healy can't pay it back, or if he needs more, he will have to make a formal humiliating application. That would mean opening Britain's books to the IMF. IMF inspectors, basically auditors, would have to fly into London to look at our books and then they would tell us what cuts we had to do in order to get the money. I mean, that would be excruciating, excruciatingly embarrassing.
英国将获得50亿美元，但有六个月的还款期。如果希利还不上，或者如果他需要更多，他将不得不进行正式的羞辱性申请。那将意味着向IMF开放英国的账簿。IMF检查员，基本上是审计员，将不得不飞往伦敦查看我们的账簿，然后他们会告诉我们为了得到这笔钱我们必须进行哪些削减。我的意思是，那将是极其、极其令人尴尬的。
And obviously people want to avoid that. Anyway, for now he's got this $5 billion to tide him over. We're into the summer. The temperature is literally rising because this is the record-breaking summer of 1976. You surely must remember this. I do. Do you have amusing anecdotes? We went camping outside Porlock, our second cousins,
显然人们想避免这种情况。无论如何，目前他有这50亿美元来度过难关。我们进入了夏天。气温确实在上升，因为这是1976年破纪录的夏天。你肯定记得这个。我记得。你有什么有趣的轶事吗？我们在波洛克（Porlock）外面露营，我们的表亲，
who we'd never met, came to meet us. They turned up, we didn't know who they were, and my brother threw a load of dry horse dung into their hair. Brilliant a story, and it reflects so well on your brother. Even then he liked war. Yeah, he did. Yes, you can take the boy out of that pit where they do the We Have Ways Festival, but you can't take the pits out of the boy.
我们从未见过面，他们来见我们。他们出现了，我们不知道他们是谁，我哥哥往他们的头发里扔了一堆干马粪。真是个好故事，这反映了你哥哥的性格。即使在那个时候，他也喜欢战争。是的，他喜欢。是的，你可以把男孩带出那个他们举办“我们有办法”节（We Have Ways Festival）的矿坑，但你无法把矿坑从男孩身上带走。
So in those days, they used Fahrenheit, so it was 90 degrees day after day. There was no rain, there was a massive drought. The trains kept breaking down. The roads were literally melting because they were using the wrong tarmac or whatever. I know you love Star Wars, Tom. This is the point at which George Lucas and Co. were filming Star Wars at Elstree,
在那些日子里，他们使用华氏度，所以气温连续几天达到90度。没有雨，发生了大规模干旱。火车不断抛锚。道路实际上正在融化，因为他们使用了错误的沥青或其他什么东西。我知道你喜欢《星球大战》，汤姆。这是乔治·卢卡斯（George Lucas）等人正在埃尔斯特里（Elstree）拍摄《星球大战》的时候，
and it was so hot that the electricians in the gantry fainted from heat exhaustion. What about the poor bloke and the tubacca? Peter Mayhew, he collapsed with dehydration while they were filming. But the green cross coat guy, he was all right, even though he's wearing black. Darth Vader. David Prowse. Didn't you meet him or something?
天气太热了，龙门架上的电工因热衰竭而昏倒。那个扮演楚巴卡（Chewbacca）的可怜家伙呢？彼得·梅休（Peter Mayhew），他在拍摄时因脱水而晕倒。但那个“绿十字代码”家伙（Green Cross Code Man），他没事，尽管他穿着黑色衣服。达斯·维达（Darth Vader）。大卫·普劳斯（David Prowse）。你没见过他吗？
I did in Salisbury Library. he came in. He came gliding in or then he said, hello boys and girls. It was not what we were expecting. No, not at all. So all that summer, as the heat is rising, Calhans ministers are arguing ferociously about the road ahead. On the one hand, Healy says, we're going to have to make these cuts. We're going to have to make them first before the IMF get here.
我在索尔兹伯里图书馆见过。他进来了。他滑了进来，然后他说：“你好，男孩女孩们。”这不是我们所期待的。不，一点也不。所以整个夏天，随着热浪上升，卡拉汉的部长们在未来的道路上争论得非常激烈。一方面，希利说：“我们必须进行这些削减。我们必须在IMF到达之前先进行削减。”
Basically, if we don't make them to appease the markets, the IMF will make them for us. And Healy wants to cut spending by more than a billion pounds, is basically two and a half percent of everybody's budget. Now, a lot of people don't agree, and they are led by our old friend Tony Ben. Are they using the word austerity at this point? Or is that a slogan of a later age? They're not using it. I think they might use it in passing every now and again, but they don't use it quite as much as would be used in the 2010s. It's not as common. But it's basically the same situation, isn't it? It's not a dissimilar situation. Now, Tony Ben says, we don't need to make any cuts at all. He has another idea, which was called
基本上，如果我们不为了安抚市场而进行削减，IMF会为我们进行削减。希利想削减超过10亿英镑的开支，基本上是每个人预算的2.5%。现在，很多人不同意，他们由我们的老朋友托尼·本领导。他们此时在使用“紧缩”（austerity）这个词吗？还是那是后来时代的口号？他们没有使用它。我想他们可能会偶尔顺便提到它，但他们使用的频率不像2010年代那样高。它没那么普遍。但基本上是同样的情况，不是吗？情况并不不同。现在，托尼·本说，我们根本不需要进行任何削减。他有另一个想法，被称为……
the alternative economic strategy with capital letters. And this was the cherished dream of the Labour left for about 15 years or so. And what this was was like capitalism is obviously terrible. Let's have a siege economy. We'll put up protectionist Trumpian tariffs. We'll have state controls. Stop British money going out. Stop foreign goods coming in.
“替代经济战略”（Alternative Economic Strategy），大写字母。这是工党左翼大约15年左右的珍视梦想。这就是像资本主义显然很糟糕。让我们建立一个“围城经济”。我们将建立保护主义的特朗普式关税。我们将进行国家控制。停止英国资金外流。停止外国商品进入。
The state should take over businesses and we should force those businesses not taken over to sign planning agreements with the government. I mean, if that sounds like a parody, I'll quote Tony Benn himself, a real labour policy of shaving jobs, import control, control of the banks and insurance companies, control of export, of capital, higher taxation of the rich, and Britain leaving the common market. Because of course this would be incompatible with European membership. When they argue about this, Dennis Healy says this is absolutely bonkers. This would destroy people's living standards. And Tony Ben says to him, no, this is the patriotic alternative to surrendering to international
国家应该接管企业，我们应该强迫那些没有被接管的企业与政府签署规划协议。我的意思是，如果这听起来像是一个模仿，我引用托尼·本自己的话，一个真正的工党政策，包括削减工作岗位、进口控制、银行和保险公司控制、出口控制、资本控制、对富人征收更高税收，以及英国离开共同市场。因为当然，这将与欧洲成员国身份不相容。当他们争论这个问题时，丹尼斯·希利说这绝对是疯了。这将摧毁人们的生活水平。托尼·本对他说，不，这是向国际资本主义投降的爱国替代方案。
capitalism. We should fight for our own people. The British establishment is now infected with the same spirit which afflicted France in 1940, the Vichy spirit of complete capitulation and defeatism. Of course, it's only what, what is it, 35 years since Vichy? But also since Haley had been storming the beaches at Antio. So Haley is absolutely outraged by this. Healy had fought. Tony Ben had been in the RF but didn't see any action.
我们应该为我们自己的人民而战。英国建制派现在感染了1940年法国所患的那种精神，即完全投降和失败主义的维希（Vichy）精神。当然，距离维希只有35年了。但也自从希利在安齐奥海滩冲锋以来。所以希利对此感到非常愤怒。希利战斗过。托尼·本在皇家空军服役，但没有参加任何战斗。
And Tony Ben describes in his diary as he says, Dennis sat there, Scarlet. He always blushes when he's in difficulty. I don't think he's in difficulty. Hewereth. Puse with rage. But actually, the cabinet agreed to support Healy. Fine, we'll cut a billion pounds in spending.
托尼·本在日记中写道，丹尼斯坐在那里，脸色通红。他一遇到困难就脸红。我不认为他遇到了困难。他怒火中烧。但实际上，内阁同意支持希利。好吧，我们将削减十亿英镑的开支。
The question is, will it be enough? So, we come to late August, which is the holiday season. Jim Callaghan has his holiday on his Sussex farm bringing in the harvest, which is Thomas Hardy's idea of fun. So that's what he's doing. Dennis Healy's idea of fun is James Boswell and Dr. Johnson's idea of fun. Oh, going to Scotland? He goes on a Scottish tour with his wife.
问题是，这够吗？时间来到八月下旬，这是度假季节。吉姆·卡拉汉在萨塞克斯郡的农场度假，忙着收割庄稼，这在托马斯·哈代看来是种乐趣。所以他就在做这些。丹尼斯·希利眼中的乐趣是詹姆斯·博斯韦尔和约翰逊博士眼中的乐趣。哦，去苏格兰？他和妻子去苏格兰旅行了。
They drive all the way up to the Isle of Sky, and then they end up in Ullapal, which is in the sort of far northwest of Scotland. And I imagine he's reading a bit of Boswell, a bit of Burns, a bit of Scott with his hinterland. He's got the Russians with him. He's probably got some Balzac, and he's very performatively piling them up at the breakfast table. Anyway, they get to this hotel at Ullupal on the key.
他们一路开车到斯凯岛，最后到达了位于苏格兰西北部偏远地区的乌拉普尔。我想他一定是在读博斯韦尔、彭斯和斯科特的作品，带着他的“腹地”。他带着俄国人，可能还带了些巴尔扎克，而且他非常刻意地把这些书堆在早餐桌上。总之，他们到达了乌拉普尔码头边的那家酒店。
They go to bed, Haley and Edna, his wife. And late at night, there's a call and he goes downstairs and it's a special branch. And they said there's an IRA death threat against you. We're sending agents. He says, fine. So he goes back upstairs to bed. Phone rings again. He goes downstairs.
希利和他的妻子埃德娜上床睡觉了。深夜，电话响了，他下楼去接，是特别行动部打来的。他们说，爱尔兰共和军对你有死亡威胁。我们正在派特工过去。他说，好吧。于是他回到楼上睡觉。电话又响了。他下楼去。
And it's the treasury this time. They say, we've got terrible news. The pound has been tanking. It's been a dreadful day. You're going to have to come back to London or something. Fine. He goes back upstairs to bed. Phone rings again.
这次是财政部。他们说，我们有个糟糕的消息。英镑一直在暴跌。今天真是糟糕透了。你得回伦敦什么的。好吧。他回到楼上睡觉。电话又响了。
He goes down. It's the Bank of England. Let's say we want permission to spend 150 million pounds to defend the pound. Yeah, fine. And by the time he gets back to London, the news has got worse. The publicity for Britain is terrible. So on the 3rd of September, more than 20,000 British Leyland car workers. We haven't really talked about car strikes.
他下楼去。是英格兰银行。他们说，我们需要批准花费1.5亿英镑来捍卫英镑。好吧，没问题。等他回到伦敦时，消息变得更糟了。英国的声誉非常糟糕。所以9月3日，超过2万名英国利兰汽车工人罢工。我们还没真正谈过汽车罢工。
Or British Leyland? In this series, I think people should just imagine that all this time, there have been constant car strikes, and the major and faulty towers has been getting very cross about them. As Red Robbo turned up? Red Robbo is the Union Convees. at Longbridge at the giant car plant in Birmingham. Do you know who loved Red Robbo?
或者英国利兰？在这个系列中，我想人们应该想象一下，一直以来都有不断的汽车罢工，而《百战天龙》里的主角对这些感到非常恼火。红罗伯出现了吗？红罗伯是伯明翰巨型汽车工厂长桥工厂的工会召集人。你知道谁喜欢红罗伯吗？
It was the two Ronnie's. They couldn't get enough of car strikes at British Leyland. Yeah, I mean, I've written a whole chapter about Red Robbo and Car Strikes at British Leyland, and I'm very happy to do. I don't feel that that would be an episode for our overseas listeners, frankly. We can indulge ourselves. To give you a little soupsaint, a little taste of what that chapter might involve, the 20,000 car workers have walked out because of a demarcation.
是两个罗尼。他们对英国利兰的汽车罢工简直乐此不疲。是的，我的意思是，我写了整整一章关于红罗伯和英国利兰汽车罢工的内容，我非常乐意这样做。坦率地说，我不觉得这对我们的海外听众来说会是一个好剧集。我们可以自我陶醉一下。为了给你一点“汤”，一点那一章可能涉及的内容，那2万名汽车工人因为一场关于谁负责——我引用一下——“按下新控制面板上的按钮”的界定讨论而罢工了。
discussion about who is responsible, and I quote, for pressing the buttons on a new control panel. And this is the kind of thing about which, you know, tens of thousands of people would go out and strike and millions and millions of pounds would be lost. And this is the 11th major strike at Longbridge in six months, which gives you a flavour of the efficiency and the ruthlessness of the British car industry. So that was on what? Was that the third of September? On the 7th of September, Labor's National Executive votes for the government to nationalize the four biggest banks. Now obviously the government are going to ignore this, but this again doesn't play well with Britain's creditors. You say obviously, if Labour Party just voted for it, why aren't they doing it?
关于谁负责——我引用一下——按下新控制面板上的按钮的讨论。这就是那种会让成千上万的人走上街头罢工，并导致数百万英镑损失的事情。这是长桥工厂六个月内的第11次重大罢工，这让你领略到了英国汽车工业的效率和无情。所以那是哪天？是9月3日吗？9月7日，工党全国执行委员会投票决定由政府将四大银行国有化。现在很明显政府会无视这一点，但这再次让英国的债权人感到不快。你说“很明显”，如果工党刚刚投票通过了，为什么他们不执行呢？
Well, Tony Ben joins us now on the rest of its history. This is exactly what Tony Ben would say. Tony Ben would say the party has just told you to nationalize the four biggest banks. You're in government. You know, you should be doing the bidding of the party. Why are you ignoring the party? And James Callaghan and Dennis Healy would say, I don't care what the party says. We'll do what we're like. That's mad. And this was a constant problem for the Labour Party, and it reaches ahead in the early 1980s when basically Ben and the activists launch a revolution against their own leadership and seize control of the party machinery from them, effectively, at the Labour Party Conference. And they said, not unreasonably, we keep voting for these things, and you just keep ignoring it, and ripping up the manifesto and doing capitalist things.
好吧，托尼·本现在加入了我们的《历史的其余部分》。这正是托尼·本会说的话。托尼·本会说，党刚刚告诉你要将四大银行国有化。你身在政府。你知道，你应该执行党的命令。你为什么要无视党？而吉姆·卡拉汉和丹尼斯·希利会说，我不在乎党怎么说。我们想怎么做就怎么做。这太疯狂了。这对工党来说是一个持续存在的问题，并在20世纪80年代初达到顶峰，当时本和激进分子基本上对他们自己的领导层发动了革命，并在工党大会上有效地从他们手中夺取了党内机器的控制权。他们说，这并非不合理，我们一直在投票支持这些事情，而你们却一直无视它，撕毁宣言，做着资本主义的事情。
Callaghan would say, well, the reason we do that is because your ideas are mad. and this is probably not a recipe for harmony with inside, you know, a major political party. Anyway, not surprisingly, the markets are losing faith in the government's ability to govern. So the Bank of England spends another 175 million pounds in an hour on the 8th of September, another 50 million pounds in 10 minutes on the 9th, and the pound keeps on falling. And on Monday, the 27th of September, it hits $1.63, its lowest level yet. Now, on the same day, Monday the 27th, the Labour Conference opens in Blackpool. You can well imagine what a happy occasion that's going to be, given what's just happened.
卡拉汉会说，好吧，我们这样做的原因是你们的想法太疯狂了。这可能不是一个主要政党内部和谐的秘诀。总之，不出所料，市场正在对政府的执政能力失去信心。因此，英格兰银行在9月8日的一小时内又花费了1.75亿英镑，在9日又在10分钟内花费了5000万英镑，而英镑持续下跌。9月27日星期一，它跌至1.63美元，创下历史新低。现在，在同一天，9月27日星期一，工党大会在黑潭开幕。你可以想象那将是一个多么快乐的场合，考虑到刚刚发生的事情。
The heat wave is over. It's absolutely pouring with rain. Because they had appointed a minister for drought, hadn't they? And then it immediately started bucketing down. Yeah. They appointed a minister for drought, and he did a rain dance, and then immediately it started. And shared his bath with his wife, didn't he? Yes, he encouraged people to save water.
热浪结束了。大雨倾盆。因为他们任命了一位干旱大臣，不是吗？然后立刻就开始下大雨了。是的。他们任命了一位干旱大臣，他跳了祈雨舞，然后立刻就开始下雨了。他还和妻子共用洗澡水，不是吗？是的，他鼓励人们节约用水。
exactly. So they all arrive in, they've been incredibly hot and sunburned and parched. And they arrive in Blackpool, which I know you love Blackpool. I'm not a massive fan, frankly. It's pouring with rain and they're all really damp and miserable. The activists are furious with the government. So speaker after speaker gets up and denounces Dennis Heed's cuts and says, we want tariffs immediately, we want protectionism, we want nationalization of the banks, who wants all this. Bernard Donahue, who's gone up with Callaghan, writes in his diary. It was really terrible. Everybody was depressed. Jim said to me it was worse than ever before. But Tony Ben is in his pomp. He loves it. He says to the conference, we are paying the price for 20 years in
没错。所以他们都到达了那里，他们之前非常热，被晒伤了，口干舌燥。他们到达了黑潭，我知道你喜欢黑潭。坦率地说，我不是它的超级粉丝。那里大雨倾盆，他们都非常潮湿和痛苦。激进分子对政府感到愤怒。所以发言者一个接一个地站起来谴责丹尼斯·希利的削减开支，并说，我们想要立即关税，我们想要保护主义，我们想要银行国有化，谁想要这一切。伯纳德·多纳休，他跟着卡拉汉去了，在日记中写道。这真的很糟糕。每个人都很沮丧。吉姆对我说，这比以往任何时候都糟糕。但托尼·本正处于他的巅峰时期。他喜欢这样。他对大会说，我们正在为过去20年付出的代价买单，
which we've played down our criticism of capitalism. It's time to fight back against the blunt and inhuman force of the market economy. And people are sobbing with joy. Yay, brilliant. Yeah, brilliant. Love it. On day two of the conference, Callahan gives his leader's speech, his first as prime minister. And this is actually one of those few speeches in modern British history that's really consequential and important. He was written by his son-in-law, Peter Jay, who was the economics editor of the Times, and was a convert to monetarism. And it's a celebrated speech, and I think one of the bravest speeches ever given by a British party leader, because Callahan gets up and he says to his party, his own party, you are totally wrong. Like we have been completely wrong. He says, and I quote, for too long we've been living on borrowed time, for too long, for too
在这20年里，我们淡化了对资本主义的批评。现在是时候反击市场经济那种迟钝而没有人性的力量了。人们喜极而泣。耶，太棒了。是的，太棒了。喜欢它。在大会的第二天，卡拉汉发表了他的领袖演讲，这是他作为首相的第一次演讲。这实际上是现代英国历史上少数几个真正具有后果和重要性的演讲之一。他是由他的女婿彼得·杰伊撰写的，彼得·杰伊是《泰晤士报》的经济编辑，也是货币主义的皈依者。这是一个著名的演讲，我认为是英国政党领袖发表过的最勇敢的演讲之一，因为卡拉汉站起来对他的党，他自己的党说，你们完全错了。就像我们完全错了一样。他说，我引用一下，太久以来我们一直靠借来的时间生活，太久以来，太久
long this country, all of us, yes, this conference too, has been ready to settle for borrowing money abroad to maintain our standards of life instead of grappling with the fundamental problem of British industry. And then he goes on to say, the cozy world of the post-war consensus has gone. We used to think that you could spend your way out of a recession and increase unemployment by cutting taxes and boosting government spending. I tell you in all candor that that option no longer exists. And insofar as it ever did exist, it only worked on each occasion since the war by injecting a bigger dose of inflation into the economy, followed by a higher level of unemployment as the next step. In other words, what we've been doing is wrong. And it didn't work
太久以来，这个国家，我们所有人，是的，这次大会也一样，一直准备通过在国外借钱来维持我们的生活水平，而不是去解决英国工业的根本问题。然后他继续说，战后共识的舒适世界已经一去不复返了。我们过去认为你可以通过增加政府支出和减税来摆脱衰退并增加就业。我坦率地告诉你们，那种选择已经不存在了。即使它曾经存在过，自战争以来的每一次，它也只是通过向经济注入更大剂量的通货膨胀，随后是更高水平的失业作为下一步才起作用的。换句话说，我们一直在做的事情是错误的。而且它没有奏效
and it's been inflationary and Keynesian economics, which is basically you spend when things are going badly to create jobs for people and stuff. Pay people to dig a hole. Pay people to dig a hole. Stop paying people to dig a hole. You're just creating to great inflation. We can't print money. We've been paying ourselves more than the value of what we produce. It's a constant. cold hard world out there. We need to cut our costs, tighten our belt, work harder and earn our place in the world. Now, you can imagine how well this goes down with his listeners. So, very unusually, right? Very unusual for an incoming prime minister in his first conference. Many of his own national executive refused to clap him. There's no standing ovation. But the other
而且它一直具有通货膨胀性，凯恩斯主义经济学，基本上就是当情况糟糕时你花钱来为人们创造就业机会之类的。付钱让人挖个洞。付钱让人挖个洞。停止付钱让人挖个洞。你只是在制造巨大的通货膨胀。我们不能印钞票。我们一直在支付给自己超过我们生产价值的工资。外面是一个持续的、冷酷的世界。我们需要削减成本，勒紧裤腰带，更加努力地工作，赢得我们在世界上的地位。现在，你可以想象这在他的听众中反响如何。所以，非常不寻常，对吧？对于一位新上任的首相在第一次大会上来说非常不寻常。他的许多全国执行委员会成员拒绝为他鼓掌。没有起立鼓掌。但其他
party's papers, the Tory papers say, what a good speech that was. You know, Jim speaks sense. Jim's facts of life, I think the Express called it. Milton Friedman, the godfather of monetarism, said a few months later, it was one of the most remarkable speeches which any government leader has ever given. Today, historians say, well, this is a massive kind of waystation on the road to thatcherism. Callahan is basically anticipating thatterism. Actually, Callahan, and he's obviously not thinking that far ahead. He's thinking, as he said to his biographer, Kenneth Morgan, he said,
党的报纸，托利党的报纸说，那是一个多么好的演讲啊。你知道，吉姆说得有道理。我想《快报》称之为“吉姆的生活事实”。货币主义的教父米尔顿·弗里德曼几个月后说，这是任何政府领导人发表过的最引人注目的演讲之一。今天，历史学家说，好吧，这是通往撒切尔主义道路上的一个巨大的中转站。卡拉汉基本上是在预示撒切尔主义。实际上，卡拉汉，他显然没有想那么远。他正如他告诉他的传记作者肯尼斯·摩根的那样，他说，
I was sick of the extremism and economic illiteracy of my party activists. I wanted them to face up to reality. But reality is about to confront all of them, in fact, about to punch them all in the face very hard. Because that same day, the 28th of September, Dennis Healy is about to fly off. The chancellor, he's not there. He's going to fly off to Hong Kong for a Commonwealth finance minister's meeting.
我厌倦了党内激进分子的极端主义和经济文盲。我希望他们面对现实。但现实即将面对他们所有人，事实上，即将狠狠地给他们所有人一记耳光。因为就在同一天，9月28日，丹尼斯·希利即将飞走。财政大臣，他不在那里。他要飞往香港参加英联邦财政部长会议。
And after Hong Kong, he's going to go to Manila for a meeting of the IMF, ironically. And all that morning, before Callaghan gates the speech, the pound has been falling. So Healy gets in the car from the Treasury to go to Heathrow Airport for his flight to Hong Kong. And during the journey from central London to Heathrow, the pound falls by another two cents. By the time he gets to the VIP lounge at Heathrow, he's in a massive dilemma. If he gets on the plane, he'll be out of communication for 17 hours. So if the pound falls more, no one will be able to talk to him or ask his advice.
在香港之后，他要去马尼拉参加国际货币基金组织的会议，讽刺的是。而在那天早上，在卡拉汉发表演讲之前，英镑一直在下跌。所以希利从财政部坐车去希思罗机场，准备飞往香港。在从伦敦市中心到希思罗机场的途中，英镑又下跌了两美分。当他到达希思罗机场的贵宾休息室时，他陷入了巨大的困境。如果他上了飞机，他将有17个小时无法联系。所以如果英镑进一步下跌，没有人能和他交谈或征求他的建议。
But if he doesn't go, the markets might completely panic, so he doesn't know what to do. And he rings Callahan and Blackpool. Callahan's about to give that speech. And Callahan, he says, I don't know what to do. And Callahan says, don't get on the plane. Forget the Far Eastern trip. Get back to the Treasury. So 15 minutes before the plane is about to leave, Healy's aides start loading his bags back off the plane and into the car in full view of the press.
但如果他不走，市场可能会完全恐慌，所以他不知道该怎么办。他给黑潭的卡拉汉打了电话。卡拉汉正要发表那个演讲。卡拉汉说，我不知道该怎么办。卡拉汉说，不要上飞机。忘了远东之行。回到财政部。所以飞机起飞前15分钟，希利的助手们开始在媒体的众目睽睽之下把他的行李从飞机上卸下来，装进车里。
An hour later, he is back at the Treasury. The trip is off. What an extraordinary thing. He's turned around at the airport. The press of course go absolutely berserk. What's going on? The Chancellor changes his plans. I mean, literally at the last minute when the plane was about to leave. And the next morning, the Treasury confirms that Healy has, after all, applied to borrow the maximum possible $3.9 billion from the IMF. This is going to be one of the great humiliations in British history. And that night, Healy goes on TV and he says to the audience, we've applied for this loan. If we don't get the loan,
一小时后，他回到了财政部。行程取消了。多么非同寻常的事情。他在机场被叫了回来。媒体当然完全疯了。发生了什么事？财政大臣改变了他的计划。我的意思是，简直是在最后一刻，飞机就要起飞的时候。第二天早上，财政部证实，希利毕竟已经申请从国际货币基金组织借入尽可能多的39亿美元。这将是英国历史上最大的耻辱之一。那天晚上，希利在电视上对观众说，我们已经申请了这笔贷款。如果我们得不到贷款，
the alternative would, and I quote, be policies so savage, I think they would lead to riots in the streets. So massive stakes, Dominic? Massive. Couldn't be higher. So is he going to get the money? How is Tony Ben going to take it? Will the Labour Party tear themselves apart? Can sunny Jim cling on? And most importantly, of all, will the sex pistols be back? Only one way to find out, come back to us after the break. It's never too early to plan your summer story in Europe with WestJet, from rolling countryside to cobblestone streets. Begin your next chapter.
替代方案将是——我引用一下——极其残酷的政策，我认为它们会导致街头骚乱。所以赌注很大，多米尼克？非常大。不可能更高了。那么他能拿到钱吗？托尼·本会怎么看？工党会分崩离析吗？阳光吉姆能坚持住吗？最重要的是，性手枪乐队会回来吗？只有一个办法可以知道，休息后回来找我们。规划你在欧洲的夏日故事，选择西捷航空，从连绵起伏的乡村到鹅卵石街道，永远不会太早。开启你的下一个篇章。
Book your seat at westjet.com or call your travel agent. WestJet, where your story takes off. There's something else here now, something new. From exclusively on Paramount Plus, it's the series Stephen King calls Scarious Hell. Everything here is impossible. But it's also real. Sci-fi vision calls it the best show streaming right now.
在westjet.com预订你的座位或致电你的旅行社。西捷航空，你的故事由此起飞。现在这里还有别的东西，一些新的东西。派拉蒙Plus独家呈现，这是斯蒂芬·金称之为“恐怖地狱”的系列剧。这里的一切都是不可能的。但它也是真实的。科幻愿景称其为目前流媒体上最好的节目。
We're running out of time and we still don't know the rules. Don't miss what the movie blog calls something you need to watch. Saving those children is how we all go home. From Binge All Episodes exclusively on Paramount Plus. Are you worried or just enjoying yourself? Enjoying myself. I've always wanted to meet you. We'll meet afterwards, shall we?
我们的时间不多了，我们仍然不知道规则。不要错过电影博客所说的你需要观看的内容。拯救那些孩子是我们所有人回家的路。从派拉蒙Plus独家观看所有剧集。你是在担心还是只是在享受自己？享受自己。我一直想见你。我们之后再见，好吗？
You dirty sod. Dirty old man. Well, keep going, Chief. Keep going. Go on. You've got another five seconds. Say something outrageous. You dirty bastard. Go on again. You dirty f***. What a clever boy.
你这个肮脏的家伙。肮脏的老头。好吧，继续，头儿。继续。来吧。你还有五秒钟。说点离谱的话。你这个肮脏的混蛋。再来一次。你这个肮脏的f***。多聪明的孩子。
What a f*** rotter. Well, that's it for tonight. Brilliant. Thank you, Dominic. Thank all, should I say, Bill Grundy. Welcome back to the rest of history. That was more archive footage from the Sex Pistols. controversial appearance on the Today Show on the early evening of Wednesday, the 1st of December, 1976.
你这个f***烂人。好吧，今晚就到这里。太棒了。谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家，我应该说，比尔·格兰迪。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。那是性手枪乐队在1976年12月1日星期三傍晚在《今日》节目中引起争议的更多档案片段。
And we'll be coming back to the Sex Pistols, won't we? But for now, there is high drama in the dimension of international finance. Top Emily Dickinson quota, Dennis Healy, with his big eyebrows. He'd been about to fly off to Hong Kong, but he's cancelled it because the economy is tanking, and now he's announced that Britain is going to have to apply to the IMF for a loan. Yes, exactly. So the timing is horrendous because the Labour Conference, of course, are meeting in Blackpool. The activists are not happy anyway, so what are they going to make of this latest surrender
我们会回到性手枪乐队，不是吗？但现在，国际金融领域出现了高潮。顶级艾米莉·狄金森语录，丹尼斯·希利，带着他那浓密的眉毛。他本来要飞往香港，但他取消了，因为经济正在崩溃，现在他宣布英国将不得不向国际货币基金组织申请贷款。是的，没错。所以时机非常糟糕，因为工党大会当然正在黑潭举行。激进分子本来就不高兴，那么他们会对这次最新的投降作何感想呢？
to the forces of international capitalism? Now, Healy had turned back at the airport on Tuesday, the 28th of September. He made the official application on the Wednesday. Now on Thursday, the 30th, there's luck-would-have-it. The conference, which is now in total sort of tumult, is due to debate economic policy. Healy wants to fly up to the conference and make his case, personally to the activists. And Callahan says to him, no, don't. It'll just inflame the delegates. They hate you already. And actually, under the Labour Party's slightly bizarre rules, if you're not
向国际资本主义势力投降？现在，希利在9月28日星期二在机场折返。他在周三提出了正式申请。现在在周四，30日，运气不错。大会，现在处于完全混乱的状态，定于辩论经济政策。希利想飞到大会现场，亲自向激进分子陈述他的理由。卡拉汉对他说，不，别去。这只会激怒代表们。他们已经恨你了。而且实际上，根据工党稍微有点奇怪的规则，如果你不是
a member of the National Executive, you won't be allowed to speak from the platform. You'll have to speak from the floor like everybody else. And so Healy says, well, fine. Well, I've made the application now. I've got nothing to do. So because he's got a great hinterland, I don't think we've mentioned that, because of his hinterland, he says, I'll spend the day at the National gallery looking at paintings from the Dutch Golden Age and I'll pick some out from my office. He goes to the National Gallery and when he's there, an official rushes in and says, Callahan's changed his mind. He wants you to go to Blackpool after all. And he's got a plane waiting at RAF North Holt to fly you to Blackpool. It's the 70s, so the plane is massively
全国执行委员会的成员，你将不被允许在讲台上发言。你必须像其他人一样在台下发言。所以希利说，好吧，没问题。我已经提出了申请。我没什么事可做。所以因为他有一个伟大的“腹地”，我想我们还没提到过，因为他的腹地，他说，我会在国家美术馆花一天时间看荷兰黄金时代的画作，我会从我的办公室挑一些出来。他去了国家美术馆，当他在那里时，一位官员冲进来，说，卡拉汉改变主意了。他还是希望你去黑潭。他在皇家空军诺斯霍尔特机场有一架飞机等着送你去黑潭。那是70年代，所以飞机被严重
delayed because of rain. And Saheli doesn't arrive in Blackpool's winter gardens until 3 o'clock and he's completely sodden and he walks in, he's incredibly red-faced. and as soon as he walks into the hall, the members of his own party start booing him, which is kind of a bad sign. He sits at the back, and the cameras are on in the whole time. And as he sits there, I mean, it's beyond parody.
延误了，因为下雨。所以希利直到3点才到达黑潭的冬季花园，他全身湿透，脸红得厉害。当他走进大厅时，他自己党的成员开始嘘他，这算是一个坏兆头。他坐在后面，摄像机一直开着。当他坐在那里时，我的意思是，这简直超出了模仿的范畴。
The conference are literally debating their plans to take Barclays Bank, Lloyd's Bank, the Midland Bank, which is now HSBC, and Nat West, into public ownership. And Healy's just sitting there, shaking his head in horror and sort of scribbling notes. And then it's his turn to speak. he is the Chancellor of the Exchequer, amid one of the worst financial crises in British history,
大会正在逐字辩论他们将巴克莱银行、劳埃德银行、米德兰银行（现在是汇丰银行）和国民西敏寺银行收归公有的计划。而希利只是坐在那里，惊恐地摇着头，胡乱地记着笔记。然后轮到他发言了。他是财政大臣，正处于英国历史上最严重的金融危机之一，
but he's not allowed onto the platform, and he's told he's got no more than five minutes to make his case. And when he watched the clip, I mean, he goes up to the front and he's not allowed onto the very top level. And he's incredibly red-faced, his tires all to skew. He looks like he hasn't slept in a week. So he's reassuring international investors in Britain, in other words. Definitely he is. And people are jeering him and shaking their fists at him and stuff. and he basically has to shout to be heard above the jeers and he says to them, I come from the battlefront and all this stuff.
但他不被允许上讲台，而且被告知他只有不到五分钟的时间来陈述他的理由。当他看片段时，我的意思是，他走到前面，他不被允许上到最高层。他脸红得厉害，领带歪歪扭扭。他看起来像一周没睡过觉一样。所以换句话说，他是在向国际投资者保证英国的情况。他绝对是。人们在嘲笑他，对他挥舞拳头之类的。他基本上必须大喊大叫才能让人们在嘲笑声中听到他的声音，他对他们说，我来自前线，诸如此类。
And then he just gets, he slams the left. He says, there are some people who would like to stop the world and get off. They say, let us go to a siege economy, but they want a siege economy of a rather odd type. They want to stop the imports coming in,
然后他只是，他猛烈抨击左派。他说，有些人想让世界停止转动然后下车。他们说，让我们进入围城经济，但他们想要一种相当奇怪的围城经济。他们想要阻止进口进来，
but to get total freedom for exports to get out. Is that true? Kind of is. Because that's never going to work. I thought that Tony Ben was saying, no, we don't, you know, we won't have any imports. No, we won't have any imports, but they never really contemplate what that means in terms of your exports.
但要让出口获得完全的自由。那是真的吗？有点像。因为那永远不会奏效。我以为托尼·本在说，不，我们不会有任何进口。不，我们不会有任何进口，但他们从未真正考虑过这对你的出口意味着什么。
Because there's no world, right, in which you say to your trading partners, we're not going to have your imports, but you have to keep buying our stuff. I mean, that obviously doesn't happen. That's never going to happen. As Healy says, I've never heard of a siege in which you keep the enemy out of your castle, but the enemy allows you to come and go as you please. And he says that, and of course, that really inflames people because they don't like being laughed at. They don't like him talking down to them. There's great howling from them at this. And then he says, I'm going to negotiate with the IMF based on my existing policies and people
因为没有一个世界，对吧，你会对你的贸易伙伴说，我们不会有你们的进口，但你们必须继续购买我们的东西。我的意思是，那显然不会发生。那永远不会发生。正如希利所说，我从未听说过一种围城，你把敌人挡在城堡外，但敌人却允许你随心所欲地进出。他说出这些话，当然，这真的激怒了人们，因为他们不喜欢被嘲笑。他们不喜欢他居高临下地对他们说话。他们对此发出了巨大的嚎叫。然后他说，我将基于我现有的政策与国际货币基金组织谈判，人们
are screaming at him, Tory policies, because they think he's a Tory, see? And he says, but when I say existing policies, I mean things we do not like as well as things we do like. It means sticking to the very painful cuts on public expenditure on which the government has already decided. And people are screaming at him, no, resign, you're a Tory and all this kind of thing. And his five minutes are up. And so he just says, that's what it means. That's what I'm going to negotiate for. And I ask the conference to support me in this task. It's redder face than ever. He goes back to his seat. As he goes back to his seat, loads of people are sort of shaking their fists at him and shouting and all this kind of thing. Are they spittle-flecked? Spittles. There's a lot of spittle. Tony Ben says in his diary, I couldn't clap him. His speech was so vulgar and abusive. It's great footage. Great TV. It's the kind of thing that basically you would never see now in British politics. But it's great fun.
对他尖叫，托利党政策，因为他们认为他是托利党，明白吗？他说，但当我提到现有政策时，我指的是我们不喜欢的事情以及我们喜欢的事情。这意味着坚持政府已经决定的非常痛苦的公共支出削减。人们对他尖叫，不，辞职，你是托利党之类的。他的五分钟时间到了。所以他只是说，这就是它的意思。这就是我将要谈判的内容。我请求大会支持我完成这项任务。他脸红得比以往任何时候都厉害。他回到座位上。当他回到座位上时，很多人都在对他挥舞拳头，大喊大叫之类的。他们唾沫横飞吗？唾沫。有很多唾沫。托尼·本在日记中写道，我无法为他鼓掌。他的演讲太粗俗和辱骂了。这是很棒的镜头。很棒的电视。这是那种你现在在英国政治中永远看不到的事情。但这很有趣。
It's terrible publicity for Britain. A few days later, the Treasury and the Bank of England had to put up interest rates to 15%, which was the highest level in history. I repeat, 15%, you know, on your borrowing, on your mortgage, whatever. This is horrendous for the economy. And the most obvious price that is paid for this is unemployment. Unemployment had started rising in the late 60s. At the end of 1971, it had reached 1 million.
这对英国来说是糟糕的宣传。几天后，财政部和英格兰银行不得不将利率提高到15%，这是历史最高水平。我重复一遍，15%，你知道，在你的借款上，在你的抵押贷款上，无论什么。这对经济来说是可怕的。为此付出的最明显的代价是失业。失业率在60年代末开始上升。1971年底，它达到了100万。
and at the time, this was under Ted Heath, people had said, God, this is the end of the world, this is the Great Depression all over again, a million people unemployed, unthinkable. And that's why Heath had thrown so much money around in an attempt to deal with it. Now under Callagham, it's more like one and a half million and nudging upwards. And it's worse for young people. So by 1979, almost half of all under 25-year-olds are out of work. So the unemployment that we associate with Thatcher and Thatcherism had already begun. And so what are you to do in that situation except become a punk rocker?
当时，这是在泰德·希思领导下，人们说，天哪，这是世界末日，这是大萧条重演，一百万人失业，不可想象。这就是为什么希思为了应对它而投入了这么多钱。现在在卡拉汉领导下，更像是150万，而且还在向上攀升。这对年轻人来说更糟。所以到1979年，几乎所有25岁以下的人中有一半失业。所以我们与撒切尔和撒切尔主义联系在一起的失业已经开始了。那么在这种情况下，除了成为朋克摇滚歌手，你还能做什么呢？
Well, this is the thing. This is the social context for the rise of punk. So the look of punk and the style of it, the kind of ripped clothes, the hair, the sort of aggression. They're there in embryo in pubs and clubs in 1975, maybe even in 1974. But it's no accident, I think, that it ceases public attention in the summer and autumn of 1976 at precisely the point when the economy is tanking, when Britain's going to the IMF, and all the newspapers are full of laments about rising unemployment and there being no future, the Sex Pistols Great Refrain.
好吧，这就是重点。这是朋克兴起的社会背景。所以朋克的外观和风格，那种撕裂的衣服，头发，那种侵略性。它们在1975年，甚至可能在1974年的酒吧和俱乐部里就已经有了雏形。但我认为，它在1976年的夏天和秋天引起公众关注并非偶然，恰恰是在经济崩溃、英国走向国际货币基金组织、所有报纸都充满对失业率上升和没有未来的哀叹——性手枪乐队的伟大副歌——的时候。
So the pistols themselves had first been mentioned by the NME in December 1975. They're all about 12 years old and they're going to be the next big thing. I left that 12 years old. But then the first really big article is by Charles Shah Murray. He reviewed my first book. That's an honour. He called me the hoodie historian. Oh, brilliant.
所以手枪乐队本身在1975年12月首次被《新音乐快递》提及。他们都大约12岁，他们将成为下一个大人物。我把那12岁留下了。但随后第一篇真正的大文章是查尔斯·沙·默里写的。他评论了我的第一本书。那是一种荣誉。他称我为“连帽衫历史学家”。哦，太棒了。
Throwing whatever passes for gang signs at the University of Sheffield. What an honour. Well, anyway, Charles Charles Charmurie wrote the first big article on the Sex Pistols. Their music is coming from the straight out of school and onto the dole death trap, which we seem to have engineered for our young, the 76 British Terminal Stasis, the modern urban blind alley. You wanted sex pistols and now you've got them. Trouble is they look like they aren't going to go away.
在谢菲尔德大学扔下任何被认为是帮派标志的东西。多么荣幸。好吧，总之，查尔斯·沙·默里写了关于性手枪乐队的第一篇大文章。他们的音乐来自直接从学校出来进入救济金死亡陷阱，我们似乎已经为我们的年轻人设计了这个陷阱，76年的英国终极停滞，现代城市死胡同。你想要性手枪乐队，现在你得到了。问题是他们看起来好像不会消失。
Now, at this point, as we alluded to earlier, they haven't actually released a record. So Anarchy in the UK didn't come out until the end of November. But just as the Beatles, in the second half of 1963, the Beatles are perfectly cast, really, to seize the moment. The newspapers love the Beatles because they seem to reflect all sorts. sorts of other trends, you know, sort of meritocracy, the northern cheekiness, all of this kind of thing that are very fashionable in 1963 and the optimism, nojolity and all the, in an age
现在，在这一点上，正如我们之前提到的，他们实际上还没有发行唱片。所以《英国无政府状态》直到11月底才出来。但正如披头士乐队在1963年下半年一样，披头士乐队被完美地塑造，真的，抓住了那一刻。报纸喜欢披头士乐队，因为他们似乎反映了各种各样的趋势，你知道，某种精英管理，北方的厚脸皮，所有这些在1963年非常时髦的东西，以及乐观主义、快乐和所有这些，在一个时代
when the economy is booming. The sex pistols seem perfectly cast to capture the mood in 1976. So Tony Parsons in the NME in early October says, they're the quintessential product of the United Kingdom in the 1970s. The music they play reflects their times, no more, no less. And then they get their first appearance a week later in the national newspapers in The Sun. The Sun did a double page spread and it illustrated it with handcuffs and swastikas. It described them as hell's angels in a clockwork orange nightmare. And it had a nice quote from John Leiden, Johnny Rotten. We want chaos to come.
当经济繁荣时。性手枪乐队似乎被完美地塑造来捕捉1976年的情绪。所以托尼·帕森斯在10月初的《新音乐快递》中说，他们是1970年代英国的典型产物。他们演奏的音乐反映了他们的时代，不多不少。然后一周后，他们在全国性报纸《太阳报》上首次亮相。太阳报做了一个双页跨版，并用手铐和纳粹标志进行了说明。它将他们描述为“发条橙噩梦中的地狱天使”。它还引用了约翰·莱顿（约翰尼·罗滕）的一句好话。我们想要混乱到来。
Life's not going to get any better for kids on the Dole until it gets worse first. It's quite like David Bowie. David Bowie in the fascism. There's a sort of nihilism, I think, in British. popular culture in the mid-70s. We want to see everything get worse, and only then will it get better? And a sort of exasperation, I think people of that generation looked at your Callahan's and your healies and your kind of trade union leaders and stuff, and they just thought, I have
在情况好转之前，靠救济金的孩子们的生活不会有任何好转。这很像大卫·鲍伊。大卫·鲍伊在法西斯主义中。我认为在英国大众文化中有一种虚无主义，在70年代中期。我们想看到一切变得更糟，只有那样它才会好转吗？我认为那一代人看着你们的卡拉汉和希利以及你们的工会领袖之类的，他们只是想，我
nothing in common with these people. I'm sick of them going on about the war. I'm sick of their massive glasses and their beer and sandwiches and their pay deals. I just want to smash everything up. And I guess you could argue they got the Prime Minister that they deserved somebody who did smash everything up. Anyway, Johnny Rotten said he wanted everything to get worse and frankly it looks as though he's going to get his wish. Because at the beginning of November, the six-man IMF team fly into London. And this is seen in the newspapers and in the media generally, and I think by the public, as a moment of overwhelming national disgrace.
和这些人没有任何共同点。我厌倦了他们谈论战争。我厌倦了他们巨大的眼镜、啤酒和三明治以及他们的薪酬协议。我只想把一切都砸碎。我想你可以说他们得到了他们应得的首相，一个确实把一切都砸碎的人。总之，约翰尼·罗滕说他希望一切变得更糟，坦率地说，看起来他要如愿以偿了。因为在11月初，六人国际货币基金组织小组飞抵伦敦。这在报纸和媒体中，我认为在公众眼中，被视为一种压倒性的国家耻辱时刻。
It's like Britain is an incompetent business that's gone into administration. and all the newspapers are on profiles of these six people. There is an Englishman, an Australian, an American, a German, a New Zealander, and a Greek. So basically, it's the cast of a terrible, very, very inappropriate 1970s joke. They're all staying at Brown's Hotel under false names, excitingly. They go to see Dennis Healy and Downing Street. Remember, he now has to open the books. He has to show them Britain's accounts.
这就像英国是一家已经进入破产管理程序的无能企业。所有的报纸都在报道这六个人的简介。有一个英国人、一个澳大利亚人、一个美国人、一个德国人、一个新西兰人，还有一个希腊人。所以基本上，这是一个糟糕的、非常、非常不恰当的1970年代笑话的演员阵容。他们都住在布朗酒店，用假名，令人兴奋。他们去唐宁街见丹尼斯·希利。记住，他现在必须公开账目。他必须向他们展示英国的账目。
And he says, you know, the books aren't ready. You'll have to hang around. so they're just hanging around London waiting for the books to be ready. Well, in Brow, I mean, that's quite nice. It's a nice hotel. It's lovely. Having tea in Browns? I mean, what a nice thing.
他说，你知道，账目还没准备好。你们得等一等。所以他们只是在伦敦闲逛，等着账目准备好。好吧，在布朗酒店，我的意思是，那很不错。那是一家不错的酒店。很可爱。在布朗酒店喝茶？我的意思是，多么美好的一件事。
But actually, the real drama isn't Britain versus the IMF. It's Callaghan's government against each other. So the issue is whether they're going to make these cuts. And this sounds like a very dry technical thing. But to any Labour government, this is absolutely existential. And there's history here. In 1931, Ramsey MacDonald's Labour government had come under similar pressure in the Depression. They too had been put under pressure to make cuts,
但实际上，真正的戏剧不是英国对阵国际货币基金组织。而是卡拉汉政府内部的对立。所以问题在于他们是否要进行这些削减。这听起来像是一件非常枯燥的技术性事情。但对于任何工党政府来说，这绝对是生存问题。这里有历史。1931年，拉姆齐·麦克唐纳的工党政府在大萧条中也面临类似的压力。他们也承受着削减开支的压力，
the pound beleaguered, and the cabinet had split, and Ramsey McDonnell, the Prime Minister, had ended up basically leaving his own party, the Labour Party, to lead a Tory-dominated coalition. And he was seen as the great traitor of Labour Party history for doing this. And the Labour Left are obsessed with this. And Tony Ben starts, at this point, he starts going to meetings with the, he gets the minutes from the cabinet meetings from 1931 and he starts performatively walking around with them under his arm, putting them out on the table for everyone to see. Because he's basically saying to Jim Callahan,
英镑陷入困境，内阁分裂，拉姆齐·麦克唐纳，首相，最终基本上离开了他自己的党，工党，去领导一个托利党主导的联盟。他被视为工党历史上最大的叛徒。而工党左派对此非常着迷。托尼·本开始，在这一点上，他开始去参加会议，他得到了1931年内阁会议的纪要，他开始刻意地夹着它们走来走去，把它们放在桌子上让每个人都看到。因为他基本上是在对吉姆·卡拉汉说，
you're Ramsey-Modonald, I know what you're like, and all this kind of thing. And also Tony Benn has lost patience with Callaghan because Callahan, he thinks, has really let himself down and let the Labour movement and socialism down. Because when Chairman Mao died, Callahan refused to have a moment of reflection. Ben was absolutely appalled that Callahan wouldn't pay tribute to Chairman Mao in British
你是拉姆齐·麦克唐纳，我知道你是什么样的人，诸如此类。而且托尼·本也对卡拉汉失去了耐心，因为卡拉汉，他认为，真的让自己失望了，也让工党运动和社会主义失望了。因为当毛主席去世时，卡拉汉拒绝进行默哀。本对卡拉汉不愿在英国内阁中向毛主席致敬感到非常震惊。
Cabinet. He says in his diary, Mao merited a moment of reflection. He will undoubtedly be regarded as one of the greatest, if not the greatest figures of the 20th century. He certainly towers above any other 20th century figure I can think of in his philosophical contribution and military genius. And the fact that Calahs He refuses to see this, he says, is a sign that Jim is just a Tory. So I think listeners can make up their own minds about this. You know, are you with Chairman Mao or you're at Jim Callahan? I know who you're with, Dominic.
他在日记中说，毛泽东值得默哀。他无疑将被视为20世纪最伟大的人物之一，如果不是最伟大的话。他在哲学贡献和军事天才方面肯定超过了我能想到的任何其他20世纪人物。而卡拉汉拒绝看到这一点，他说，是一个迹象，表明吉姆只是一个托利党。所以我认为听众可以自己下结论。你知道，你是支持毛主席还是支持吉姆·卡拉汉？我知道你支持谁，多米尼克。
Are you with Chairman Mao? I'm not with Chairman Mal. I hate Chairman Mao. Chairman Mao is a terrible man. He's an absolutely terrible man. He made war on birds. And this sign of Tony Ben's terrible, terrible judgment. I mean, I like Judge Callaghan.
你是支持毛主席吗？我不支持毛泽东。我讨厌毛泽东。毛泽东是一个可怕的人。他是一个绝对可怕的人。他向鸟类宣战。这是托尼·本可怕的、可怕的判断力的标志。我的意思是，我喜欢吉姆·卡拉汉。
Yeah, he's great. I like the fact he's from Hampshire, I like the fact he had a farm, I like the fact that he approved the Royal Navy. No, I like him. So, Callahan and He'll have a problem with Tony Benn. He despises them now for their lack of affection for Chairman Mao, but also their enthusiasm for cuts. The other person they have to worry about is the Foreign Secretary, who is called Anthony Crosland. I mentioned him briefly. Oh, the lounge lizard.
是的，他很棒。我喜欢他来自汉普郡，我喜欢他有一个农场，我喜欢他批准了皇家海军。不，我喜欢他。所以，卡拉汉和希利在托尼·本那里遇到了问题。他现在鄙视他们，因为他们对毛主席缺乏感情，也因为他们对削减开支的热情。他们必须担心的另一个人是外交大臣，名叫安东尼·克罗斯兰。我简要地提到了他。哦，那个“休息室蜥蜴”。
Lounge lizard. Actually, I basically fell down a rabbit hole of looking at photographs online of Tony Crosland, trying to find the appropriate terminology. He looks uncannily, I think, like David Cameron. He's like a sort of more lounge lizard-esque David Cameron. Kind of fleshy? He's become quite fleshy, Rubicund. He's much more baggy-faced by this point
休息室蜥蜴。实际上，我基本上掉进了一个在网上看托尼·克罗斯兰照片的兔子洞，试图找到合适的术语。他看起来惊人地，我认为，像大卫·卡梅伦。他就像某种更像休息室蜥蜴的大卫·卡梅伦。有点肉感？他变得相当肉感，红润。到这个时候，他的脸变得更加松弛了，
because he's proving we've been drinking a lot more on smoking and stuff. He was the great intellectual of the Labour Party in the 50s. He wrote a book with The Future of Socialism. And he basically said Britain should become a Scandinavian social democracy with American lifestyle. So massive tax. says huge fridges. His dream has been overtaken by events, but he still hankers after this sort of 1950s, 1960s, 1960s, Keynesian dream of like, let's tax and spend loads and all this.
因为他证明了我们一直在喝更多的酒和抽烟之类的。他是50年代工党的伟大知识分子。他写了一本《社会主义的未来》。他基本上说英国应该成为一个拥有美国生活方式的斯堪的纳维亚社会民主国家。所以大规模减税。说巨大的冰箱。他的梦想被事件超越了，但他仍然渴望这种50年代、60年代、60年代的凯恩斯主义梦想，比如，让我们征税并大量支出之类的。
And he also sees Heli's arrival, and he wants to use this against him. So his argument is, it's mad to have any cuts. We've got a million people unemployed. What are we thinking? It'll provoke loads of strikes. Just tell the AMF that are being stupid. A cat, Crosland, like Healy is incredibly arrogant. He says, just tell the IMF, they're fools. Just done they're wrong and they'll have to listen. So Callahan has this problem. He has got the foreign secretary against him. He's got Ben against him and he's got the IMF. How is he going to handle this and keep his government together? And the answer is that he actually handles it brilliantly. It's one of the great examples of prime ministerial management in British history. I think it was cited by Daniel
他也看到了希利的到来，他想利用这一点来对付他。所以他的论点是，进行任何削减都是疯狂的。我们有一百万人失业。我们在想什么？这会引发大量的罢工。只要告诉国际货币基金组织他们很愚蠢。一只猫，克罗斯兰，像希利一样非常傲慢。他说，只要告诉国际货币基金组织，他们是傻瓜。只要说他们错了，他们就必须听。所以卡拉汉有这个问题。他有外交大臣反对他，他有本反对他，他有国际货币基金组织。他将如何处理这个问题并保持他的政府团结？答案是他实际上处理得非常出色。这是英国历史上首相管理的伟大例子之一。我认为它被丹尼尔·芬克尔斯坦在《泰晤士报》中引用为一个基尔·斯塔默可以学习的例子。那是很高的评价。因为你知道，丹尼·芬克尔斯坦，你知道他的爱好之一是什么吗？是一个叫《历史的其余部分》的播客。他是《历史的其余部分》的忠实粉丝。你好，丹尼。我希望你喜欢那个提及。是的，他应该在《泰晤士报》上再写一篇专栏。关于我们有多好。
Finkelstein in the Times as an example that Kirstama could learn from. That's high praise. Because you know, Danny Finkelstein, do you know what one of his enthusiasms? It's a podcast called The Rest Is History. He's a big fan of The Rest is History. Hello, Danny. I hope you enjoyed that mention. Yeah, he should write another column in The Times. About how good we are.
芬克尔斯坦在《泰晤士报》上的文章可以作为斯塔默学习的一个例子。这可是极高的赞誉。因为你知道，丹尼·芬克尔斯坦，你知道他热衷于什么吗？是一个叫《历史余温》的播客。他是《历史余温》的忠实粉丝。你好，丹尼。希望你喜欢这次被提及。是的，他应该在《泰晤士报》再写一篇专栏，夸夸我们有多棒。
That's exactly what he should write two columns. One about how good Jim Callahan is and one about how good we are. And everyone will enjoy that. So what Callahan does in the next two months, he has 26 cabinet meetings. And he basically says to his ministers, fine, you talk this out. You taught yourselves into exhaustion. and I'll be the umpire. And that's what he does. And basically Healy, the Chancellor, has to do 26 of these meetings where he allows his colleagues to argue with him, and he basically
这正是他应该写两篇专栏文章的原因。一篇写吉姆·卡拉汉有多好，另一篇写我们有多好。每个人都会喜欢这样。所以卡拉汉在接下来的两个月里做了什么呢？他召开了26次内阁会议。他基本上对他的部长们说，好吧，你们把这件事讨论清楚。你们讨论到精疲力竭为止，而我来当裁判。这就是他所做的。基本上，财政大臣希利不得不参加这26次会议，他允许同事们与他争论，而他基本上
has to fight back. And he's working these punishing days. He's redder than ever. He gets shingles. But he puts up a tremendous performance, because this is what he's all about, basically fighting off. He loves a fight. He loves a bare-knuckle intellectual brawl. Does he have any time off to read Emily Dickinson? No. He's having a terrible time. He's starting work at six and working until midnight, almost like our routine. Yes, that'll be about to.
必须进行反击。他每天都在进行高强度的折磨式工作。他的脸比以往任何时候都红。他得了带状疱疹。但他表现得非常出色，因为这就是他的全部意义所在，基本上就是抵御攻击。他喜欢争斗。他喜欢赤手空拳的智力搏斗。他有时间去读艾米莉·狄金森吗？没有。他过得非常糟糕。他早上六点开始工作，一直工作到午夜，几乎和我们的作息一样。是的，差不多就是这样。
So they have all these meetings. I guess the key one is the 23rd of November. Not only in the arguing with each other, they're arguing with the IMF. And Healy has persuaded the IMF to moderate their demands, so Britain will have to make one and a half billion dollars of cuts next year and another $3 billion in 1978, 79. Healy says to his colleagues, look, this will be very painful, but the IMF will approve it, the Americans will approve it, it'll be good for a image, it'll be good for confidence, let's do this. Crossland then speaks up and he says, this is mad.
所以他们开了所有这些会议。我想最关键的一次是11月23日。他们不仅在互相争论，还在与国际货币基金组织（IMF）争论。希利说服了国际货币基金组织放宽要求，因此英国明年将不得不削减15亿美元的开支，并在1978至1979年再削减30亿美元。希利对他的同事们说，看，这会非常痛苦，但国际货币基金组织会批准，美国人会批准，这对我们的形象有好处，对信心有好处，我们这样做吧。克罗斯兰随后发言说，这太疯狂了。
He says, and I quote, tell the IMF the Americans and the Germans, if you demand any more of us, we should put up the shutters, wind down our defence commitments and introduce a siege economy. Now this, Crosland says, this will frighten them. They need our troops in West Germany. And they don't want us to have a siege economy and to be a North Korea. off the coast of France. So they will blink. They will give us the money and they won't demand any cuts
他说，我引用一下，告诉国际货币基金组织、美国人和德国人，如果你们再对我们提出更多要求，我们就关门大吉，缩减我们的国防承诺，并实行围城经济。现在，克罗斯兰说，这会吓到他们。他们需要我们在西德的军队。他们不希望我们实行围城经济，也不希望我们成为法国海岸边的一个北韩。所以他们会退缩的。他们会给我们钱，而且不会要求任何削减，
and we'll be laughing. So it's a bit Brexit. It's very Brexit. It's very Brexit. It's basically we'll blackmail the IMF. They need us more than we need them. Now, we tried that with the European Union in the late 2010s, didn't we?
我们到时候就会笑出声来。所以这有点像英国脱欧。这非常像英国脱欧。这非常像英国脱欧。基本上就是我们要勒索国际货币基金组织。他们需要我们胜过我们需要他们。现在，我们在2010年代末尝试过这一点，不是吗？
And I don't feel it worked out brilliantly, personally. I'm not expressing a view about Brexit. I'm expressing a view about a negotiating strategy. And I feel like the claim that German carmakers, We were so important that they would come to our rescue. That was not realized. Anyway, there was obviously no way the IMF would give in to this blackmail. This is absolutely mad.
而且我个人觉得效果并不好。我不是在表达关于英国脱欧的观点。我是在表达关于谈判策略的观点。我觉得那种认为德国汽车制造商因为我们太重要了，所以他们会来拯救我们的说法，并没有实现。总之，国际货币基金组织显然不可能屈服于这种勒索。这绝对是疯狂的。
But a lot of Callahan's ministers quite like this because they will do anything to avoid the cuts. Again, Callahan plays it very cleverly. He says, look, take a week to think about it. We'll come back in a week. We'll come back next Wednesday and we'll make up our minds one way or the other. And over the weekend, he and Crosland have to go to the Hague for some European meeting. And on the way back, Callahan says to Crossland, whatever happens, I'm going to side with Dennis. I'm telling you now, I'm siding with Dennis.
但卡拉汉的许多部长很喜欢这个主意，因为他们会不惜一切代价避免削减开支。卡拉汉再次表现得非常聪明。他说，看，花一周时间考虑一下。我们一周后再回来。我们下周三回来，我们要么做出这个决定，要么做出那个决定。周末，他和克罗斯兰不得不去海牙参加某个欧洲会议。在回来的路上，卡拉汉对克罗斯兰说，无论发生什么，我都要站在丹尼斯这边。我现在就告诉你，我站在丹尼斯这边。
And the implication is, if you keep fighting, you will bring down this government. And none of us want that. So the week goes by and we get to the decisive day, which is Wednesday, the 1st of December. Callahan's ministers arrive at number 10. They're told there's a half-hour delay, which is very unusual for a cabinet meeting. And the reason is that Callahan has been locked in the upstairs room, or not locked, in, but he's been in an upstairs room. If he was locked in, that'd be a bit weird.
言下之意是，如果你继续争斗，你就会搞垮这个政府。我们谁都不想那样。一周过去了，我们迎来了决定性的一天，也就是12月1日，星期三。卡拉汉的部长们抵达唐宁街10号。他们被告知会议推迟了半小时，这在内阁会议中非常罕见。原因是卡拉汉一直被锁在楼上的房间里，或者说不是被锁在里面，而是待在楼上的房间里。如果他被锁在里面，那会有点奇怪。
Oh, by Hester Thrail. Yeah, yes, exactly. Barcy Williams has come back and lock them in the room so they can't have lunch. With the managing director of the IMF, who's flown in from Washington, and Callahan has persuaded him to drop the one and a half billion cuts to just one billion cuts in the first year. So that's a bit of a win. A win for Britain.
哦，是被海丝特·思雷尔锁住的。是的，没错。巴尔西·威廉姆斯回来了，把他们锁在房间里，这样他们就不能吃午饭了。他与从华盛顿飞来的国际货币基金组织总裁进行了会谈，卡拉汉说服他将第一年的削减额从15亿美元降至10亿美元。所以这算是一次胜利。英国的胜利。
Callahan finally comes downstairs. It's 10.30. He says, we'll go round the table and we'll decide what we're going to do. He starts with Tony Ben of the critics. and Tony Ben says, let's have a siege economy. Come on, let's become North Korea. And this completely backfires because basically Callahan's staff have secretly been preparing ammunition to use against Tony Ben. And they've distributed it to Callahan's younger loyalist ministers who are people like Shirley Williams and Bill Rogers. He go on to form the breakaway Social Democratic Party in the 80s.
卡拉汉终于下楼了。时间是10点半。他说，我们围着桌子坐，决定我们要怎么做。他从批评者托尼·本开始。托尼·本说，让我们实行围城经济吧。来吧，让我们成为北韩。这完全适得其反，因为卡拉汉的幕僚们已经秘密准备了弹药来对付托尼·本。他们把这些弹药分发给了卡拉汉年轻的忠诚部长们，比如雪莉·威廉姆斯和比尔·罗杰斯。他在80年代继续组建了分裂出来的社会民主党。
And they get absolutely stuck into Ben. The questions that you were asking, Tom, who's going to be? going to lend us any money if we have a siege economy. How many people will lose their jobs because no one's buying our exports? What do you think our trading partners will do if you ban their imports? They're not going to buy British goods anymore. What are you going to do about that? And Ben has to admit that he doesn't know the answers to these questions. And it's very sad. People start laughing at him. They start laughing at him and making fun of him in the meeting. And Callahan actually has to intervene and to tell them to listen to him with respect because they're
他们完全把本给难住了。汤姆，你问的那些问题，谁会借钱给我们，如果我们实行围城经济的话？如果我们没人买出口产品，会有多少人失业？如果你禁止他们的进口，你认为我们的贸易伙伴会怎么做？他们不会再买英国商品了。你打算怎么办？本不得不承认他不知道这些问题的答案。这非常可悲。人们开始嘲笑他。他们在会议上开始嘲笑他，取笑他。卡拉汉实际上不得不进行干预，告诉他们要尊重地听他说话，因为他们
being nasty to Tony Ben. So that's Tony Ben, and then it's Croslin, the Foreign Secretary. Croslund wants his blackmail plan. He says, let's threaten a siege economy, or talk about our role in Cyprus or our troops in Germany or our membership of the EEC, and then Schmidt, the German Chancellor and Ford, the US president, will soon give way. But in the last week, people have been talking about this, and they've lost some of their former enthusiasm.
对托尼·本太刻薄了。所以那是托尼·本，然后是外交大臣克罗斯兰。克罗斯兰想要他的勒索计划。他说，让我们威胁实行围城经济，或者谈谈我们在塞浦路斯的角色，或者我们在德国的军队，或者我们作为欧洲经济共同体成员的身份，然后德国总理施密特和美国总统福特很快就会让步。但在过去的一周里，人们一直在谈论这件事，他们失去了一些最初的热情。
You know, the more he sort of says, it'll be fine, they'll give him. Of course they'll blink. people think, were they really? Probably they won't. And so that night, the night of Wednesday, the 1st of December, loads of ministers come to Crosland's room in the Commons. They say, we're not going to support you. We're going to support Dennis.
你知道，他越是说，没关系，他们会给的。当然他们会退缩的。人们就想，真的吗？可能他们不会。所以那天晚上，12月1日星期三晚上，许多部长来到下议院克罗斯兰的办公室。他们说，我们不会支持你。我们要支持丹尼斯。
And actually, Crosland himself finally cracks, and he goes to see Jim Calhann. He says, I'm still right, but I guess I'll go along with you. Now, while this has been going on in the House of Commons, there's been another dramatic development. because that evening Thames TV's early evening
事实上，克罗斯兰本人最终崩溃了，他去见了吉姆·卡拉汉。他说，我仍然认为我是对的，但我猜我会顺从你。现在，当这一切在下议院发生时，还有另一个戏剧性的发展。因为那天晚上泰晤士电视台的傍晚
family friendly today show was going to feature everyone's favourite band Queen but Queen pulled out because Freddie
家庭友好型今日节目本来要邀请大家最喜欢的乐队皇后乐队，但皇后乐队退出了，因为弗雷迪
had to go to the dentist is that right he had to go to the dentist that's a good fact so their publicists at EMI said to the bookers at Thames we've got another group join our other group instead
不得不去看牙医，是这样吗？他不得不去看牙医，这是一个很好的事实。所以他们在EMI的公关人员对泰晤士电视台的预订员说，我们有另一个组合，加入我们的另一个组合吧。
and they said, sure, what could possibly go wrong? And this was the sex pistols. This was the genesis of their interview with Bill Grundy. So listeners will now have heard the original archive footage, weren't they? And so you, listening to this, will be able to make up your own minds about what was going on. The pistols, as you say, Tom, thought that Bill Grundy was drunk. I don't think he seems that drunk when you actually see the real archive. But he, I mean, maybe he's such a kind of consummate drunk that he can get away with it.
他们说，当然，能出什么错呢？这就是性手枪乐队。这就是他们接受比尔·格兰迪采访的起源。所以听众现在应该已经听过原始的档案录音了，不是吗？所以，听着这个的你，将能够自己判断当时发生了什么。正如你所说，汤姆，手枪乐队认为比尔·格兰迪喝醉了。当你真正看到真实的档案时，我不觉得他看起来那么醉。但他，我的意思是，也许他是一个如此老练的酒鬼，以至于他能蒙混过关。
I mean, Michael Parkinson said he was always drunk. Yeah, I know lots of people said he was a big drinker. But if so, then he would have been drunk and done loads of today programs. It's hard to work out exactly why he loses it so completely. Because actually, although people always used that, or used it at the time, the newspapers said, oh, the pistols are scum and all this kind of thing, the swearing, it's kind of not their fault because he goes them. He tells them to do it.
我的意思是，迈克尔·帕金森说他总是喝醉。是的，我知道很多人说他是个大酒鬼。但如果是这样的话，那他应该会喝醉并做很多今日节目。很难弄清楚他为什么会完全失控。因为实际上，尽管人们总是使用那个，或者在当时使用它，报纸说，哦，手枪乐队是人渣之类的，那些脏话，这其实不是他们的错，因为是他激怒了他们。他告诉他们要那样做。
Go on, Chief. Say something outrageous. and all this kind of thing. The result is this massive media furori. So I'm going to read a line that I've used so often in my books, but I don't really know what it means. The switchboard is jammed. I never know what that works.
来吧，伙计。说点离谱的话。诸如此类。结果是这场巨大的媒体骚动。所以我打算读一行我在书中经常用到，但我并不真正知道它是什么意思的句子。总机被占线了。我从来不知道那是什么意思。
How many calls must you get? And I also how many people realistically are ringing TV companies? Anyway, 10 people are ringing terms of TV, whatever. The switchboard is jammed. And the next day's papers go completely berserk. we have these tremendous headlines. The filth and the fury. Fury at filthy TV chat.
你得接到多少电话？而且我也想知道现实中有多少人会给电视公司打电话？总之，有10个人在给泰晤士电视台打电话，随便吧。总机被占线了。第二天报纸完全疯了。我们看到了这些惊人的头条新闻。污秽与愤怒。对污秽电视谈话的愤怒。
And the BBC get the blame, don't they? Even though it wasn't on the BBC. I love this. Daily Express published a long editorate explaining why this was all the BBC's fault. Even though it wasn't on the BBC and the BBC had nothing to do with it. But the Express aren't going to let a little thing like that get in the way. No, the Express said it's the BBC's fault because the BBC panders to the ignorance and tastelessness. of those who enjoy the noises of punk rock.
英国广播公司（BBC）受到了指责，不是吗？尽管它不是在BBC播出的。我喜欢这个。每日快报发表了一篇长篇社论，解释为什么这一切都是BBC的错。尽管它不是在BBC播出的，而且BBC与此毫无关系。但快报不会让这种小事阻碍他们。不，快报说这是BBC的错，因为BBC迎合了那些喜欢朋克摇滚噪音的人的无知和低俗。
I love that, the noises of punk rock. Anyway, it completely changed the lives of the sex pistols this interview because it made them household names. Their plasters across the newspapers. It meant that from this point onwards, it would be impossible for them ever to be judged on the basis of their music.
我喜欢那个，朋克摇滚的噪音。总之，这次采访彻底改变了性手枪乐队的生活，因为它让他们家喻户晓。他们的照片贴满了报纸。这意味着从这一点开始，他们将不可能再仅仅根据他们的音乐来被评判。
And they've got Silver Jubilee coming up. They've got the Silver Jubilee. Perfect timing. Exactly. And they become this, even though their music is not that popular. they become a genuine public phenomenon. They become the supreme emblems of the breakdown and nihilism of the 1970s. And this before they've ever really had a hit.
他们即将迎来银禧庆典。他们有银禧庆典。时机完美。完全正确。他们成为了这个，尽管他们的音乐并不那么受欢迎。他们成为了一个真正的公众现象。他们成为了1970年代崩溃和虚无主义的最高象征。而这还是在他们真正拥有热门歌曲之前。
And as for Bill Grundy, Tom, a terrible fate, Bill Grundy. A warning from history. A warning from history. He literally ends up being banished to present a books podcast. So the next morning, the 2nd of December, as Callahan's ministers assemble for another meeting, the papers are full of the pistols. but I'm happy to say there is no filth and fury in Downing Street. Very good.
至于比尔·格兰迪，汤姆，一个可怕的命运，比尔·格兰迪。历史的警告。历史的警告。他最终真的被流放去主持一个书籍播客。所以第二天早上，12月2日，当卡拉汉的部长们聚集在一起开另一次会议时，报纸上全是关于手枪乐队的报道。但我很高兴地说，唐宁街没有污秽和愤怒。非常好。
Look at that, that's elegant writing. So good. So Callahan and Healy of Wom. Crosson throws in the towel. Ben's grumpy about it, but the cabinets will take the deal. Britain will cut public spending by a billion pounds next year and one and a half billion pounds the year afterwards, and in return it'll get $4 billion right now to defend the pound.
看那个，那是优雅的写作。太棒了。所以卡拉汉和希利赢了。克罗斯兰认输了。本对此感到不满，但内阁会接受这个协议。英国明年将削减10亿英镑的公共支出，后年削减15亿英镑，作为回报，它现在将获得40亿美元来捍卫英镑。
It is at once a total humiliation for, Britain and a great political achievement by Callahan because he hasn't lost a single minister. He's kept his government together. This was a crisis that was brewing before he became PM and he's somehow come out of it with his reputation enhanced. And even Tony Ben, who is usually, what did he Callahan call him? A canting hypocrite. And Tony Ben who is usually so scathing about any other Labour politician. Yeah, Harold Wilson's birthday, odious. Odious. In his diary, he wrote afterwards, Jim is a much better Prime Minister than Wilson. He's much more candid and open with people.
这既是对英国的彻底羞辱，也是卡拉汉的一项伟大政治成就，因为他没有失去任何一位部长。他保持了政府的团结。这是一场在他成为首相之前就在酝酿的危机，而他不知何故从中脱颖而出，声誉反而得到了提升。甚至托尼·本，他通常，卡拉汉称他为什么？一个虚伪的伪君子。而托尼·本通常对任何其他工党政客都非常尖刻。是的，哈罗德·威尔逊的生日，可恶。可恶。他在日记中后来写道，吉姆比威尔逊好得多，是一位更好的首相。他更坦率，对人更开放。
He doesn't try to double talk them as Wilson did. Wilson has simply disappeared from sight. Nobody thinks about him anymore. So, 10 days before Christmas, they unveil the deal to the House of Commons. There are going to be big cuts to all the budgets. There's going to be higher charges for things like gas and telephones, which of course in these days in the 70s are public utilities. But the Labour Left don't rebel. Amazingly, Callahan and Healy have got away with it. There's a little twist to the story. It actually turned out that because the Treasury had got their figures wrong, Britain was borrowing less money than everybody thought.
他不像威尔逊那样试图用双重语言欺骗他们。威尔逊已经从人们的视野中消失了。没人再想起他了。所以，在圣诞节前10天，他们向议会公布了这项协议。所有预算都将大幅削减。天然气和电话等费用将会提高，当然在70年代这些是公用事业。但工党左派没有反叛。令人惊讶的是，卡拉汉和希利成功了。故事还有一个小转折。事实证明，因为财政部搞错了数据，英国借的钱比大家想象的要少。
So Healy only needed half of the loan and was able to repay it early. Now, of course, people don't know that initially. And at the time, people saw this as the whole business was seen as an abject national humiliation. And on the left, as well as on the right, there's a brilliant editorial in the Sunday Mirror. Perhaps the politicians who have got us into our present mess would like to know what the British people are fed up with most of all. Not the fall in the pound, not ever-rising food prices, not the erosion of their pay packets, not even the weather.
所以希利只需要贷款的一半，并且能够提前偿还。现在，当然，人们最初并不知道这一点。在当时，人们认为这件事是一场彻头彻尾的国家羞辱。在左派和右派中，星期日镜报有一篇精彩的社论。也许那些让我们陷入目前困境的政客们想知道英国人民最厌倦的是什么。不是英镑的下跌，不是不断上涨的食品价格，不是工资袋的缩水，甚至不是天气。
What the British people are fed up with most is feeling ashamed. Oh, that's terrible, isn't it? As for the political significance of this moment, historic significance, it depends where you stand. So if you're like Tony Benn and you're on the left, you see this moment, the IMF bailout, as the definitive moment in British history when socialism was betrayed. So in the 1980s, the left of the Labour Party, lots of Labour activists, said, Callahan and Healy were the people who prepared the way for Margaret Thatcher, and they never forgive them for it.
英国人民最厌倦的是感到羞耻。哦，那太可怕了，不是吗？至于这一时刻的政治意义，历史意义，取决于你的立场。所以如果你像托尼·本一样站在左派，你会把这一时刻，即国际货币基金组织的救助，视为英国历史上社会主义被背叛的决定性时刻。所以在1980年代，工党左派，许多工党活动家说，卡拉汉和希利是为玛格丽特·撒切尔铺平道路的人，他们永远不会原谅他们。
Well into the 80s, when Healy would get up to give a speech, activists would scream, IMF, at him. They'd kind of chanted at him. Now, if they hadn't won, what if Tony Benn had got his way? And we had had a siege economy. I mean, I think it's very unlikely, but I don't think the result would have been very good. I think it had been high inflation, tanking living standards. I think there would have been a surge in unemployment, and there probably have been an even
直到80年代，当希利站起来发表演讲时，活动家们会对他尖叫“国际货币基金组织”。他们会对他高喊。现在，如果他们没有赢，如果托尼·本得逞了呢？如果我们实行了围城经济。我的意思是，我认为这不太可能，但我不认为结果会很好。我认为那将是高通胀，生活水平暴跌。我认为失业率会激增，而且可能会有更
greater swing to the right eventually. And actually, François Mitterrand tried something a little bit similar in France, in the 1980s. He gave it up after two years or something, didn't he? And he got Jacques Delors in to sort out his finances and to a swing to the right towards austerity. So the French did try it, and it did. really work. And I don't think it would have worked in Britain. However, I think Ben is right
大的右转。事实上，弗朗索瓦·密特朗在1980年代的法国尝试过类似的事情。他在两年左右后就放弃了，不是吗？他让雅克·德洛尔来整理他的财政，并转向右翼的紧缩政策。所以法国人确实尝试过，而且确实奏效了。我不认为它在英国会奏效。然而，我认为本在
in one respect. I think this was a big turning points, and I think he's actually right that Callahan and Healy do prepare the ground for Margaret Thatcher to some degree, because in the space of a few months, what they've basically done is they've ditched tax and spend Keynesianism, they've abandoned the idea of full employment, and they're moving towards what later seen as monetarism. So a year later, a year after this, 1977, Healy said to his cabinet colleagues, he said, we'll never again live in a Britain where everybody has a job.
一个方面是对的。我认为这是一个巨大的转折点，而且我认为他实际上是对的，卡拉汉和希利在某种程度上确实为玛格丽特·撒切尔铺平了道路，因为在短短几个月内，他们基本上所做的是抛弃了税收和支出的凯恩斯主义，放弃了充分就业的想法，并转向了后来被视为货币主义的东西。所以一年后，一年后，1977年，希利对他的内阁同事说，他说，我们再也不会生活在一个每个人都有工作的英国了。
Canaanism has failed. And in 1979, there's a telling exchange which Ben records in his diaries between him and Callaghan about globalisation. So Ben says, how is it that British businesses are allowed to order coal from Australia and ships from Japan just because they're cheaper than British
凯恩斯主义已经失败了。而在1979年，本在他的日记中记录了他和卡拉汉之间关于全球化的一次发人深省的交流。所以本说，为什么英国企业被允许从澳大利亚订购煤炭，从日本订购船只，仅仅因为它们比英国
products. That shouldn't be allowed. And Callahan says to him, we mustn't be insular, Tony. You know, the state can't do anything about this. If those goods are cheaper, we should buy them from wherever they come from. And of course, in our lifetimes, we have grown up thinking that he was right and that, you know, free trade and globalization of the way forward. But we now, in the 2020s, find ourselves in an age when the US president, I'm guessing, would have said that Tony Ben was right and that you should always put your own country first. and that who cares. You know, if tariffs are what you need, then tariffs is what you do.
产品便宜。那是不应该被允许的。卡拉汉对他说，我们不能狭隘，托尼。你知道，国家对此无能为力。如果那些商品更便宜，我们应该从它们来源的任何地方购买。当然，在我们的一生中，我们成长过程中认为他是对的，你知道，自由贸易和全球化是前进的方向。但我们现在，在2020年代，发现自己处于一个时代，我猜美国总统会说托尼·本是对的，你应该永远把自己的国家放在第一位。谁在乎呢。你知道，如果关税是你需要的，那么关税就是你所做的。
Though Tenny Ben wouldn't have approved of attacking Iran, would he? No, I think that's probably the only respect in which they would be singing from the same hymn sheet, I guess. Anyway, Tony Benn much less orange. And I don't think Donald Trump has been stung on his penis by a wasp. That fact that may not even be true. Of course it's true, Dominic. Well, it's on the rest of history, so it must be. It's the single most important fact of postal British politics.
虽然托尼·本不会赞成攻击伊朗，对吧？不，我想那可能是他们会唱同一首歌的唯一方面，我想。总之，托尼·本没那么橙色。而且我不认为唐纳德·特朗普的阴茎被黄蜂蜇过。那个事实甚至可能不是真的。当然是真的，多米尼克。好吧，它在历史的其余部分，所以它一定是。这是英国战后政治中最重要的事实。
So anyway, this whole story ends with Britain a lot closer to Thatterism, the end of 1976 than it was when we began at the beginning in 1975. To Thatcherism, but not to Thatcher. Because people may be wondering, you know, they started the series with Margaret Thatcher becoming leader, where has she been in all this? And the truth is, she's not been relevant. She's not part of the story. She's been Tory leader all this time, but she's been struggling in the House of Commerce.
所以总之，整个故事以英国在1976年底比我们在1975年开始时更接近撒切尔主义而告终。接近撒切尔主义，但不是接近撒切尔。因为人们可能想知道，你知道，他们以玛格丽特·撒切尔成为领导人开始了这一系列，她在这一切中在哪里？事实是，她一直不相关。她不是故事的一部分。她一直都是保守党领袖，但她在下议院一直在挣扎。
still. Callahan is brilliant at dealing with her in a very, I have to say, a very sexist way. He basically pats her on her head when she gets up to oppose him. And at one point he actually uses the expression, now, now little lady to her, which drives her mad, but everybody kind of laughs. He is miles ahead in polls of who people would prefer as Prime Minister, even with the Tory press. He's remarkably popular. And that Christmas, the rabidly right-wing Daily Express says, perhaps we are quite lucky in old Jim Callahan. But his luck is about to run out because we will come back to the 1970s later on, not immediately, but later on, in a third and final series, which will come to the Winter of Discontent, the election of 1979,
仍然。卡拉汉在处理她时非常出色，我必须说，以一种非常性别歧视的方式。当她站起来反对他时，他基本上会拍拍她的头。有一次他甚至对她使用了“好了，好了，小女士”这样的表达，这让她发疯，但每个人都笑了。他在谁更适合担任首相的民调中遥遥领先，即使在保守党媒体中也是如此。他非常受欢迎。那个圣诞节，狂热的右翼每日快报说，也许我们很幸运拥有老吉姆·卡拉汉。但他的运气快要用完了，因为我们稍后会回到1970年代，不是立即，而是稍后，在第三个也是最后一个系列中，我们将谈到不满之冬，1979年的选举，
and Margaret Thatcher's transformation from an ugly duckling into an Argentine smiting swan. And that is all ahead. But Dominic, just because people are going to have to wait a year now for more 1970s Britain doesn't mean that there is going to be any lack of history in the intervening months. So we have coming up, the Mona Lisa, Battle of Marison, First World War, the Tudor Cold War, the Odyssey, loads and loads of stuff to come. And if you are an Athelstan, then we have an unbelievable treat for you because coming up is going to be the opportunity to win not just a copy of Dominic's great book, Seasons and
以及玛格丽特·撒切尔从丑小鸭到阿根廷天鹅的转变。这一切都在前面。但是多米尼克，仅仅因为人们现在要等一年才能看到更多1970年代的英国，并不意味着在接下来的几个月里会缺乏历史。所以我们即将推出，蒙娜丽莎，马里森战役，第一次世界大战，都铎冷战，奥德赛，还有很多很多东西。如果你是Athelstan，那么我们有一个令人难以置信的款待，因为即将到来的是赢得不仅是多米尼克伟大的书《太阳下的季节》的副本，
the Sun, but a signed copy. So if you're in Athelstown and you want to be in with a chance of winning, just add your email address to the form in the episode description. But for now, Dominic, thank you. No one better in the whole world to talk about. Britain in the 1970s and you. So what a treat it's been. Thank you everyone for listening. And we will be back with the Mona Lisa. next week. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. We have reached the thrilling climax to our epic mini-series about photography and history, which is exclusively for our Restis History Club members.
而且是签名副本的机会。所以如果你是Athelstan，并且你想有机会获胜，只需将你的电子邮件地址添加到剧集描述中的表格中即可。但现在，多米尼克，谢谢你。世界上没有人比你更适合谈论1970年代的英国了。所以这真是一种享受。谢谢大家的收听。我们将带着蒙娜丽莎下周回来。再见。再见。我们已经达到了我们关于摄影和历史的史诗迷你剧的激动人心的结局，这是专门为我们的Restis历史俱乐部成员准备的。
So we thought we would give you one last taste of this series that we're doing with the great photographer Chris Floyd. And in this, the climactic episode, we're looking at the story of technology and photography. How inventions like the Lyca and Polaroid, the Flash and the strobe have transatlantic transformed the way we see the world and the way that we understand modern history. It really is a richly fascinating and colourful episode,
所以我们想让你最后一次品尝我们与伟大的摄影师克里斯·弗洛伊德一起制作的这个系列。在这一集，也就是高潮的一集中，我们正在审视技术和摄影的故事。像莱卡和宝丽来、闪光灯和频闪灯这样的发明是如何跨大西洋改变了我们看待世界的方式以及我们理解现代历史的方式。这确实是一个非常迷人且丰富多彩的剧集，
and we're going to give you a little snippet of it right now. And that's what Kodchrome does. It allows you to bring out the colour. So suddenly the world, I always think this makes such a difference in the way we view the recent past. We think of it in terms of black and white and colour. We find it hard, I think, to empathise for people who live in a black and white world rather than the colour one. They just seem old-fashioned and stuffy. the Kaiser or something because he's black and white they move in a jerky way in the film of the
我们现在要给你一个小片段。这就是柯达彩色胶卷的作用。它让你能够展现色彩。所以突然间世界，我一直认为这在我们看待近期过去的方式上产生了如此大的差异。我们认为它是黑白和彩色的。我认为我们很难同情那些生活在黑白世界而不是彩色世界的人。他们看起来只是老式和沉闷。凯撒之类的，因为他是黑白的，他们在当时的电影中动作生硬，我们感到与他们非常疏远，而一旦你看到彩色的东西，我不知道，越南战争之类的，它感觉就像今天一样，是的，它极大地影响了我们对近期过去的思考方式。我们在某种集体记忆中看待那个时期的方式，从40年代到70年代，是由柯达彩色胶卷的外观定义的，是柯达彩色胶卷让我们思考那个时期。所以当你进入50年代时，你有一位名叫恩斯特·哈斯的摄影师，他用彩色记录了纽约，全部使用柯达彩色胶卷。当我们认为纽约在50年代是一个彩色前景时，我们对它的思考方式是由柯达彩色胶卷的颜色定义的。你有这些深沉、丰富的红色，相反，红色，它们不会互相渗透和泄漏。它们保持着非常清晰的定义。
time and we feel very distance from them whereas as soon as you see something in color i don't know vietnam war or something it feels like it could be today yeah and it affects the way that we think about the recent past so much of the way we see that period in our sort of collective memory from the say the 40s to the 70s um is defined by the look of kodachrome it's kodachrome that makes us think about that. So when you go into the 50s, you have a photographer called Ernst Haas, who documented New York in color, all on Kodochrome. How we think of New York in the 50s, when we think of it as a color prospect is defined by the colors of Kodakram. You have these deep, rich reds, opposites, the reds and they don't bleed into each other and leak. They remain really sharply defined.
好吧，你在这些大萧条时期的农民照片中看到了这一点。它们，我的意思是，它们真的，真的看起来不像1930年代的照片。你可以看到皮肤的纹理，你几乎可以看到每一个毛孔。它们有一种，几乎是一种高清晰度的外观。你知道我在想什么吗？是的。而且它们看起来也像我们。我的意思是，它们看起来像我们认识的人。
Well, you get that in these photos of farmers in the Depression. They're, I mean, they really, really don't look like 1930s photographs. You can see the texture. of the skin, you can almost see every pore. There's a kind of, almost a kind of high definition look to them. Do you know what I think? Yeah. And they also look like us. I mean, they look like people we would know.
我的意思是，它们是，你知道，它们看起来像住在那里的人。他们住在哪里？我会说他们住在像恩斯通这样的地方。真的，离我们很近？是的。在北牛津郡。是的。它们看起来像恩斯通人。
I mean, they are, you know, they look like people that live in. Where do they live? I would say they live in somewhere like Endstone. Really, near us? Yeah. In North Oxfordshire. Yeah. They look like Endstone people.
哇。在伍德斯托克和奇平诺顿之间的恩斯通田野里劳作。好吧，这对听众来说是一个小众参考。非常感谢你们的收听。现在，如果你想听到那一集，这个史诗系列中的前三集以及我们的其他迷你剧，Rest is History Club，那么你所要做的就是前往therestis history.com。找到注册页面。就在那里。非常简单。你可以在几次点击中加入。它的价值非常高。所以带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢你们的收听，再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Wow. Toiling in the fields of Enstone between Woodstock and Shipping Norton. Okay. Well, that's a niche reference there for the listeners. Thank you so much for listening to that. Now, if you want to hear that episode, the preceding three episodes in this epic series and our other mini-series, The Rest is History Club, then all you need to do is to head to the rest is history.com. Find the sign-up page. It's right there. It's dead simple. You can join in just a couple of quicks. It's amazingly good value. So on that bombshell, thank you very much for listening and goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哇。在伍德斯托克和奇平诺顿之间的恩斯通田野里辛勤耕耘。好吧，这对听众来说是一个非常冷门的梗。非常感谢你们的收听。现在，如果你想收听那一集、这个史诗系列的前三集以及我们的其他迷你系列《历史余温俱乐部》，那么你只需要前往therestishistory.com。找到注册页面，就在那里。非常简单。你只需点击几下就能加入。性价比超高。那么，以这个重磅消息结束，非常感谢大家的收听，再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。